ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM. SARGE'S
ARE TO PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND
BRING THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE
CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL
AGUIAR-CURRY. ARAMBULA OUR QUE
HAN BENNETT BERMAN HELLO BLOOM
BOERNER HORVATH BONTA BRIAN
BURKE CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES CHEN CHOI COOLEY
COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY DAILY
DAVIES FLORA FONG FRIEDMAN
GABRIEL GALLAGHER CRISTINA
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON
GRAY GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN JONES
SAWYER KALRA KILEY LACKEY LIII
LEVINE. LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN QUINN
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS RADIUS THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO C. R. TO SMITH STONE D.
BALLOT AREAS VIA FOOD RAW VOEPEL
WALDRON WARD WEBER WICKS WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A QUORUM
IS PRESENT. A QUORUM IS PRESENT
IN THE ASSEMBLY. WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE REAR
CHAMBER. AND IN THE GALLERY TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN IMAM
YASIR KHAN HIMANTA SIR. IN THE
NAME OF GOD THE MOST GRACIOUS
THE MOST MERCIFUL. GOD OF ALL
CREATION AND SOURCE OF UNENDING
PEACE. HELP US TO DO GOOD WORK.
MAY ONLY TRUTH BE SPOKEN HERE.
GIVE TO THOSE STANDING IN THIS
CHAMBER THE WISDOM TO KNOW THEIR
WEAKNESS THE HUMILITY TO
ACKNOWLEDGE YOUR STRENGTH. AND
THE COURAGE TO LET JUSTICE BE
THE SOLE MOTIVATOR TO DO THEIR
WORK. BY THEIR LOVE FOR THEIR
COUNTRY AND FOR THEIR FELLOW
CITIZENS. MAY DESERVE WELL DOES
. WHO SENT THEM TO THIS PLACE
MAY DAY LEAD TO BY FOLLOWING YOU
. THE AUTHOR OF ALL TRUTH. AND
SHOW THE WAY BY CHERISHING YOUR
PRESENCE IN THEIR HEARTS I MEAN. THANK YOU BOB YES SIR WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE. PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BALLOT THERE'S A
SHE LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE
MISTER. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO
THE FLAG. AS OR- WHICH IS WELL-
INDIVIDUALS WITH BEING ASKED FOR
ALL. THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL. ASSEMBLY GERMAN
SACRAMENTO THURSDAY JANUARY
TWENTIETH TWENTY TWENTY TO THE
SUMMIT NINE AM ON A REQUESTFOR
A MORE ACTING SPEAKER OF THE
ASSEMBLY PRESIDING CHIEF CLERK
SUPERCAPACITOR FOLKS YOU PROPER
READING WILL CALL THE ROLL WAS
CALLED ASSEMBLY MEMBER MIA BONTA
BROUGH CORPORAL THE ASSEMBLY
MOTION CARRIES ON ANDREAS MOVES
. AND MISS WALDRON SECONDS THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
EXHORTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE. INTRODUCTION REFERENCE
OF BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED. MESSAGES FROM
THE GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE THERE
ARE NONE- TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THERE ARE NO
ABSENCES TODAY. AND MS RACE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
PROCEDURAL MOTIONS THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
FRIEDMAN CHOI AND SALAS TO SPEAK
ON AND ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY
TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE ONE EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY TO ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBER
NAZARIAN THEY HAVE A GUESTS AND
PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE FLOOR TODAY
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION. AT THE
REQUEST OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON PLEASE MOVE ITEM SEVENTY
FIVE AB ELEVEN SIXTY FIVE TO THE
INACTIVE FILE. THE CLERK WILL
KNOW. AT THE REQUEST OF A SET AT
THE REQUEST OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS I AM GIVING A ONE
DAY NOTICE TO REMOVE ITEM EIGHT
TWENTY NINE S. B. THREE FORTY
NINE AMBURG FROM THE INACTIVE
FILE. CLERK WILL AGAIN NOTE.
MEMBERS WE HAVE SPECIAL GUESTS
WITH US IN THE CHAMBER TODAY.
MEMBERS. MEMBERS PLEASE DIRECT
YOUR ATTENTION TO MISTER
NAZARIAN. WHO WILL BE SPEAKING
FROM MY DESK IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER. MR IN THIS AREA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THE- THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES-
AS WE'RE GETTING READY TODAY FOR
THE FINAL DAY OF VOTING FOR THE
TWO YEAR BILLS- I I'M THANKFUL
TO ALL OF YOU FOR GIVING ME
ALLOWING ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
RECOGNIZE SOMEONE WHO'S BEEN
EXTREMELY SPECIAL TO ME OVER THE
COURSE OF AT LEAST THE LAST THE
NINE YEARS SINCE I'VE BEEN IN
OFFICE- WE ALL DEPEND AND WE'VE
HEARD THE SPEECHES NOW ON
SEVERAL OCCASIONS WHEN LONG TERM
STAFFERS ARE RETIRING AND MOVING
ON FROM THIS BUILDING. BUT AND
WE ALL HEAR ABOUT WHAT A
WONDERFUL CONTRIBUTION SOME OF
THESE INDIVIDUALS MAKE NOT JUST
TO US BUT TO THE BENEFIT OF THE
INSTITUTION AND TO CALIFORNIA-
BUT SOMETIMES AMONG SOME OF THE
STAFF AND I'M NOT. TAKING
PERSONAL PRIVILEGE AND CHOOSING
ONE OVER THE OTHER. SOMETIMES
AMONG THE STAFF ARE ALSO THOSE
WHO HELPED BUILD THE NEXT
GENERATION OF STAFFERS. WHO ARE
THE ONES THAT MENTOR MANY
INDIVIDUALS WHO BECOME CHIEFS OF
STAFF FOR OTHER MEMBERS OR LEDGE
DIRECTORS FOR OTHER MEMBERS. AND
THEIR LEGACY LEAVES BEHIND
NUMEROUS INDIVIDUALS IN VARIOUS
DIFFERENT OFFICES- AND I'M VERY
PROUD TO BE JOINED TODAY BY A
DEAR FRIEND AND A FORMER. A
STAFFER OF THIS BUILDING WHO IS
IN THIS BUILDING FOR TWENTY FIVE
YEARS AS CHIEF OF STAFF HE CAME
INTO THE BUILDING AS A CHIEF OF
STAFF. WITH THEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GILL CDO CONTINUED ON TO THE TO
BEING HIS CHIEF OF STAFF AND THE
SENATE CAME BACK FOR A TERM TO
THE ASSEMBLY. AND THEN GOT BY ME
FOR THE LAST NINE YEARS. TO BE
MY CHIEF OF STAFF. AND THE SO IN
IN IN THE RESOLUTION THAT WE-
DRAFTED FOR HIM I DUBBED HIM AS
THE CHIEF OF CHIEFS NO
DISRESPECT TO THE WONDERFUL
CHIEFS WHO HAVE BEEN IN THE
BUILDING FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS
THIRTY YEARS. BUT AGAIN IT TAKES
A CERTAIN INDIVIDUAL WITH A
CERTAIN LEVEL OF PATIENCE. AND
CHARACTER AND ABILITY TO
CULTIVATE THE NEXT GENERATION OF
MULTIPLE CHIEFS SOME OF WHOM ARE
SITTING RIGHT HERE ABOVE THERE.
IT'S WONDERFUL TO BE JOINED BY
SUE AND THE FAMILY. AS WELL AS
SOME OTHER STAFF MEMBERS WHO
HAVE BEEN CULTIVATED BY THE MAN
STANDING BEHIND ME. AND IT'S
WONDERFUL ALSO TO SEE OTHER
FELLOW CHIEFS WHO RETIRED JUST
ABOUT A YEAR YEAR AND A HALF
AGO. JOHN SCRIBNER IN THE
GALLERY AS WELL- IN THE GALLERY
AS WELL SO. I WANTED TO TAKE
THIS OPPORTUNITY. AND- RECOGNIZE
DANS AMAZING WORK- IT DOESN'T
GET MORE. ECCENTRIC THAN DAN
SAVAGE THIS IS. A DEAD HEAD WHO
BECAME A MARINE WHO THEN WENT TO
STUDY- AT UCLA AND GOT A MASTERS
IN PLANNING. AND THEN WENT TO
WORK FOR A UNION. TO THEN LEAVE
AND COME TO THE LEGISLATURE I
MEAN IT IT THIS GUY'S DONE AT
ALL. AND THE BREADTH OF
EXPERIENCE THAT HE'S BROUGHT TO
THIS BUILDING. HAS BENEFITED
THIS BUILDING TREMENDOUSLY SO ON
BEHALF OF MYSELF AND THE
WONDERFUL SENATOR. ALWAYS A
SENATOR AND NOW COUNCILMAN LOS
ANGELES THANK YOU ALL FOR
HONORING DAN SAVAGE THANK YOU.
YEAH. AND MISTER SPEAKER FINAL
THOUGHT. THIS IS ERIN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED AGAIN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER- WHEN I TOOK
OFFICE I WANTED TO FIND A WAY OF
HONORING A PAST TRAUMA. AND SO
INSTEAD OF JUST HAVING A
RESOLUTION FOR THE ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE AS A COMMEMORATION ON
AN ANNUAL BASIS I WANTED TO
FIGURE OUT A WAY WHERE- THE
CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA CAN LEARN
ABOUT MAN'S INHUMANITY TO MAN.
AND SO THAT WE USE THE PAIN AND
SUFFERING OF THE PAST AS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE FORWARD AND
BETTER OURSELVES. AND SO WORKING
WITH DAN WECAME UP WITH THE
CONCEPT OF AN ESSAY CONTEST FOR
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS. AS WELL AS
AN ART CONTEST WE'VE BEEN DOING
ANNUALLY. AND SO IN ONE OF THE
YEARS- THE ARTIST THAT DREW THIS
PORTRAIT. IN MY HAND. DAN WAS
JUST SO TAKEN BY IT HE WAS THE
ONE LEADING ALL OF THESE
EFFORTS- THAT- HE PUT THAT
PLACED THESE THIS WATER COLOR
PAINTING. IN HIS ROOM BUT IT
NEVER GOT FRAMED. AND SO I
WANTED TO FRAME IT AND HAVE
SOMETHING THAT HE REMEMBERS HIS
LEGACY OF CONTRIBUTIONS BY. IN A
MILD WAY SO. I JUST WANTED TO
PRESENT THIS TO DAN AS WELL AS
AS A AT LEAST ONE A SYMBOLIC
POINT OF HIS WORK IN
CONTRIBUTIONS HERE. THANK YOU
DAN. THANK YOU.
OKAY MEMBERS WE
ARE MOVING TO BUSINESS ON THE
DAILY FILE. GOVERNOR'S VETOES
FILE ITEMS ONE THROUGH FORTY
THREE SHALL BE CONTINUED ON
RECONSIDERATION. IDMS A
RECONSIDERATION SHALL BE
CONTINUED. ON THE ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING FILE. FILE ITEMS FORTY
FIVE AND FORTY SIX PASS AND
RETAIN. WE ARE GOING TO TAKE UP
FILE ITEM. FORTY SEVEN. AB TWO
FIFTY SEVEN. IN THE CORPORATION
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO FIFTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN AND OTHERS
NOT REALLY THE FOOD FACILITIES
AND EMPLOYMENT MR HOLDING YOU
MAY OPEN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. AS A FORMER SMALL
BUSINESS FRANCHISE OWNER. I KNOW
FIRST HAND THE DIFFICULTIES THAT
COME WITH RUNNING A FRANCHISE
BUSINESS. THE EXPERIENCE I HAVE
HAD AS A FRANCHISEE MOTIVATED ME
TO AUTHOR LEGISLATION SUCH AS AB
FIVE TWENTY FIVE IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN TO PROTECT FRANCHISEES
AGAINST THE ARBITRARY
TERMINATION OF THEIR CONTRACTS.
THOSE EXPERIENCES PROMPTED ME TO
TAKE AUTHORSHIP OF ASSEMBLY BILL
TWO FIFTY SEVEN. CALIFORNIA HAS
A CHANCE TO LEAVE THE COUNTRY
AND ADDRESS LONG STANDING ISSUES
IN THE FAST FOOD INDUSTRY. BY
CREATING A STATEWIDE FAST FOOD
SECTOR COUNCIL. DESPITE THE FAST
FOOD INDUSTRY IS RAPID GROWTH IN
CALIFORNIA'S PRIVATE SECTOR
EMPLOYEES WAGES CONTINUE TO
REFLECT SOME OF THE LOWEST IN
THE STATE. ADDITIONALLY FAST
FOOD WORKERS OFTEN EXPERIENCE
WAIT STAFF. ASKMEN UNSAFE
WORKPLACE CONDITIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN A TESTIFIED BY THE PANDEMIC
. IN RESPONSE TO THE PANDEMIC
NUMEROUS LAWS AND REGULATIONS
WERE CREATED WITH THE INTENTION
OF PROTECTING WORKERS FROM
INFECTION AND ALLOWING THEM TO
REST AND RECOVER WITHOUT FEAR OF
LOSING THEIR LIVELIHOOD.
UNFORTUNATELY EMPLOYERS HAVE
CONTINUOUSLY FAILED TO INFORM
THEIR WORKERS OF THEIR RIGHTS
AND HAVE EVEN PRESSURED
EMPLOYEES TO CHOOSE BETWEEN
WORKING IN UNSAFE CONDITIONS. OR
LOSING THEIR JOBS. IN THE
MEANTIME WORKERS CONTINUE TO
FILE COMPLAINTS AND DOCUMENT
VIOLATIONS OF CODED SAFETY
MEASURES PUBLIC HEALTH LAWS AND
LABOR LAWS. AB TWO FIFTY SEVEN
WILL ADDRESS THESE ISSUES BY
HOLDING CORPORATE FRANCHISORS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR ENSURING
FRANCHISEES COMPLY WITH STATUTES
THAT EMPLOYERS ARE EXPECTED TO
FOLLOW. THIS COMPONENT IS
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT AS I'M
CURRENTLY WORKING ON ASSEMBLY
BILL SIX SEVENTY SIX WHICH WILL
MAKE AMENDMENTS TO AB FIVE
TWENTY FIVE AN INSURER FRANCHISE
STORES DO NOT CONTINUE TO
CIRCUMVENT CALIFORNIA LAW. AB
TWO FIFTY SEVEN WOULD ALSO
PROHIBIT RETALIATION AGAINST
WORKERS FOR EXERCISING THEIR
RIGHTS AND PROTECTING PROTESTING
AGAINST UNSAFE WORKING
CONDITIONS. SEVERAL HAVE RAISED
CONCERNS THAT THIS BILL TAKE
AWAY THE LEGISLATURE'S AUTHORITY
TO CREATE REGULATIONS IMPACTING
THE FAST FOOD INDUSTRY. IT DOES
NOT. THE LEGISLATURE. THE
SPEAKER. YOU GOT ME WORKING A
LITTLE BIT TOO HARD UP HERE. THE
LEGISLATURE SIMPLY DIRECT THE
COUNCIL TO IMPLEMENT POLICY AND
STANDARDS CREATED BY THE
LEGISLATURE. THIS IS CONSISTENT
WITH CURRENT RELATIONSHIPS
BETWEEN THE LEGISLATURE THE CPUC
AND KERR THIS BILL DOES NOT
IMPROPERLY DELEGATED LEGISLATIVE
AUTHORITY BECAUSE THE
LEGISLATURE IS PERMITTED TO
PROVIDE REASONABLE GRANTS THE
POWER. TO ADMINISTRATIVE AGENCY
AS LONG AS SUITABLE TO
SAFEGUARDS ARE ESTABLISHED. JUST
TO NAME A FEW THE WORKERS
COMPENSATION BOARD. OFFICE OF
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH HAZARD
ASSESSMENT ARMINA TALK TO
SUBJECT SUBSTANCE IN CONTROL.
BERMAN A PESTICIDE REGULATIONS
AS I SAID JUST TO NAME A FEW. I
HAVE ENGAGED WITH STAKEHOLDERS
AND TKEN AMENDMENTS THAT WILL
REQUIRE THE COUNCIL TO SUBMIT
STANDARDS TO THE LEGISLATURE
BEFORE BECOMING REGULATION.
GIVEN A SIXTY DAYS TO WEIGH IN
AND REQUIRED A PERFORMANCE
REVIEW OF THE COUNCIL THREE
YEARS. AMONG OTHER AMENDMENTS
AND YET I'M STILL OPEN TO
TIGHTENING UP. THE BILL WHERE
APPROPRIATE. FOR EXAMPLE I AM
OPEN TO EXTENDING THIS REVIEW
PERIOD TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY
DAYS. I WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS
THE CONCERNS SURROUNDING
FRANCHISE OR FRANCHISEE JOINT
LIABILITY. I'M AWARE OF THE
POTENTIAL FOR UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES WITH THE APPROACH
HOWEVER I WANT TO ASSURE MEMBERS
THAT THE SPONSORS AND I REMAIN
COMMITTED TO ADDRESSING CONCERNS
AS THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD.
MEMBERS IN THE SENATE MAY HAVE
SIMILAR RESERVATIONS SO WE WILL
CONTINUE CONSIDERING AMENDMENTS.
THAT IMPROVE THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN FRANCHISE STORE IN
FRANCHISEE. WHILE MAINTAINING
ADEQUATE PROTECTION FOR WORKERS
. I'M DEMONSTRATING MY
WILLINGNESS TO ADDRESS CONCERNS
JUST AS RECENTLY AS LAST WEEK BY
REMOVING THE COUNCIL'S AUTHORITY
TO ISSUE SUBPOENAS. I'VE HEARD
THE CONCERNS OF ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH ADMINISTRATORS AND I'VE
TAKEN THEM SERIOUSLY. I'M
ADDRESS THEIR TO CONCERNS
REGARDING ENFORCEMENT OUT OF
THEIR JURISDICTION. WE WILL WORK
TO ADDRESS THEIR REMAINING
CONCERNS REGARDING NOTIFICATIONS
I'M HAPPY TO CONTINUE DISCUSSING
A REASONABLE WAY TO ADDRESS
FRANCHISE OR RESPONSIBILITY IN
THESE MATTERS THIRTY SECONDS
HOLDEN I'M ALSO HAPPY TO ADDRESS
TO DISCUSS HOW WE CAN ENSURE
GEOGRAPHICAL DIVERSITY. ON THE
COUNCIL SO THAT BOTH RURAL AND
URBAN FRANCHISEES ARE HEARD.
THIS BILL IS ABOUT CREATING
EQUITY AND INCLUSION FOR FAST
FOOD WORKERS AND FRANCHISEES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MR HOLDER MISTER COOLEY YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. COLLEAGUES I
RISE AGAIN IN OPPOSITION THIS
BILL AYE OPPOSED TO LAST SUMMER
I DO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THERE ARE
CHANGES MADE. I ACTUALLY DON'T
FEEL THEY CURE THE ISSUES OF.
AFFECTING THE ABILITY THE LETTER
TO RESPOND. HI. THE AUTHOR HAS
STATED HE WOULD EXTEND THE
REVIEW PER TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
DAYS BUT TO GIVE A REVIEW TO THE
LEGISLATURE WHO AN ONLY SPEAK
TO REGULATIONS BY THE ADOPTION
OF STATUTES AND SAVES SIXTY DAYS
A HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS. THIS IS
REALLY A BILL WRITTEN. TO
UNDERMINE THE ABOVE THE
LEGISLATURE TO HONESTLY WEIGH IN
ON THESE ISSUES. AND I'M
ACTUALLY CONCERNED THAT AS A
MEMBER. I SEE MANY BILLS COMING
THROUGH. WHERE WE DO TO
OURSELVES THIS WE PASS BILLS.
THAT UNDERMINE THE POWER OF THE
LEGISLATURE EXEMPT THINGS ON THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURES ACT.
HI OUR HANDS WE CAN ONLY OFFER
COMMON SIXTY DAYS WHEN THEY HAVE
TO HAVE A BILL. THERE IS ONLY
ONE BODY OF LINE CALIFORNIA WERE
SIXTY DAY WINDOW ACTUALLY IS
USEFUL THE LEGISLATURE TO WEIGH
IN. AND THAT'S IN THE LONG.
STATE REORGANIZATIONS WHICH IS
FOUND IN THE CONSTITUTION. OF
THE REORG LOG GOVERNOR CAN BRING
FOR THE PLAN AND ANY EVEN A
SINGLE HOUSE THE LEDGER COULD
OBJECT TO IT WITHIN SIXTY DAYS
AND IS DEAD. THAT IS NOT WHAT WE
HAVE HERE. WE HAVE RULES BEING
BROUGHT FOR JUSTICE FOR THE LOST
AWAY AND OFFER A COMMENT. BUT
WITH A SIXTY OR A HUNDRED TWENTY
DAY IT IS JUST NOT WELL FOUNDED
. TO RESPECT THE WAY THIS BODY
RESPONSES A BODY I RICHARD I'VE
OR UNTIL. THANKS COOLEY. MR SAY
ARE TELL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
OF THE ASSEMBLY I TO STAND IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWO FIFTY SEVEN
. YOU KNOW THEY'RE ALREADY.
LABOR LAWS THAT AFFECT ALL ALL
BUSINESSES INCLUDING FAST FOOD
THE FAST FOOD INDUSTRY. AND IF
SOMEONE WHO GOT HIS START IN A
FAST FOOD RESTAURANT. IT'S NOT A
FUN JOB BUT YOU KNOW WHAT IT IS
A JOB AND THEY DIDN'T HAVE LABOR
LAWS AND WE HAD TO FOLLOW THE
LABOR LAWS. AS I WAS WHEN I
BECAME A MANAGER- ALL OF THOSE
THINGS ARE TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT
BUT RIGHT NOW WE HAVE
FRANCHISEES THAT ARE STRUGGLING
IT RECOVER FROM THE PANDEMIC.
THIS IS NOT A GREAT TIME TO HIT
YET ANOTHER UNELECTED BOARD-
OVERSEE SPECIFICALLY THEM. AND
IN ADDITION TO MANY OF THE OTHER
AGENCIES THAT WERE ALREADY
POINTED OUT EARLIER. THIS IS THE
LIABILITY THAT IS BEING EXTENDED
FROM THE FRANCHISOR WILL HAVE A
CHILLING EFFECT ON BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA. BECAUSE FRANCHISORS
. WILL SIMPLY NOT GRANT
BUSINESSES THE FRANCHISEES IN
ALIFORNIA AND YOU WILL SEE SOME
OF THE MOST POPULAR FRANCHISE
FRANCHISES GROW IN OTHER AREAS
AND WONDER WHY CALIFORNIA
DOESN'T GET TO HAVE THOSE. SO IT
ENTER IT JUST DRIVES ENTIRE
FRANCHISES. AND FRANCHISE BRANDS
AWAY FROM CALIFORNIA. SO IT IS
FOR THESE REASONS THAT I ASK YOU
TO CAST A NO VOTE ON THIS BILL.
AND PROTECT THE FRANCHISEES THAT
WE HAVE THE WORKERS HAVE THE
PROTECTION THEY NEED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. DR QUIRK YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED YES- I REGRETFULLY A
RISE IN OPPOSITION TO AB TWO
FIVE SEVEN AM I DO REGRET BEING
IN OPPOSITION. THERE IS CLEARLY
A PROBLEM IN THE FAST FOOD
INDUSTRY I JUST DON'T THINK
HAVING A SEPARATE SET OF
REGULATIONS FOR THE FAST FOOD
INDUSTRY IS THE WAY TO DO IT I
THINK ENFORCEMENT IS WHAT WE
NEED. I THINK THE FRANCHISORS
COULD HELP WITH THAT- FOR
EXAMPLE THIS GROUP COULD SERVE A
SEPARATE MINIMUM WAGE FOR FAST
FOOD WORKERS OR FRANCHISE
WORKERS. AND WHY SHOULD A
FRANCHISE OF WORKERS MAKE MORE
THAN THE DISHWASHER TO SIT DOWN
RESTAURANT OR CHILD CARE WORKER
OR MADE AT A HOTEL. I WISH AND
NEWSPAPER STORIES COMPLAINING
ABOUT SEXUAL HARASSMENT THAT HAS
TO BE FIXED BUT THAT'S ALREADY
ILLEGAL. WE DON'T NEED NEW
REGULATIONS WE NEED BETTER
ENFORCEMENT OF THE RULES WE
HAVE. I BELIEVE THAT THE
FRANCHISE OR SHOULD HAVE A ROLE
IN THEM FOR SHIPMENT. FOR ME TO
SUPPORT THE BILL IT NEEDS TO BE
CHANGED. TO NOT BRING SEPARATE
REGULATIONS. TO WHERE INDUSTRY.
BUT TO ENFORCE THE REGULATIONS
WE HAVE ON ALL INDUSTRIES AND IN
PARTICULAR THERE SHOULD BE A
ROLE FOR THE FRANCHISE STORES.
WHAT I WOULD SUPPORT HURON THE
FRANCHISE OR BE RESPONSIBLE IN
SOME WAY FOR THE BEHAVIOR THE
FRANCHISEE. THEY INSPECT FOR
FOOD QUALITY AND CLEANLINESS
THEY CAN EXPECT. HOW WELL THE
STAFF IS TREATED. TO THE OFFER I
HOPE YOU CAN FIND A WAY TO HELP
THE STAFF AND FRANCHISEES I JUST
DON'T THINK THIS IS THE WAY TO
DO IT. THANK YOU. THANK GOD COR
MISTER COOPER. YOUR RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER PHONE
CAN IN AUTHOR FOR TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS AND IN DOING THE BILL
THERE. IN MY OPINION IS NOT
WHERE IT NEEDS TO BE REALLY BAD
BIG ISSUE IS. BRUTAL LEGISLATURE
WE FOUGHT TO GET HERE WITH THE
ONE SELECTED FOR THE ONE THAT
PEOPLE CALL. IN TO HAVE AN
ELECTED BODY. THEY CAN DO
WHATEVER THEY WANT IT JUST
DOESN'T SIT RIGHT- I HAVE MY
CONSIDER FOR A DAILY BASIS WE
HAVE ISSUES. WITH BODY HAS NO
REGULATION OVER THEM. YOU
MENTIONED CARB NCPC. MANY TIMES
ALLEGE THE TRUCK TALK TO CARD
ENROLLED. AND GOTTEN ZERO
RESPONSE FROM KERR. IT'S MOSTLY
SHE'S ON THE C. P. U. C. SO.
IT'S FOR. THAT WE'RE GONNA
ADVOCATE THAT AND LIKE I SAID- I
THOUGHT TO BE HERE. AND THE WAS
HARD. IS A LOT OF US HAD A HARD
TIME GETTING HERE AND WHY WOULD
EVER ADVOCATE AUTHORITY ONE ELSE
I JUST CAN'T DO THAT- YOU KNOW
IT'S TOUGH BEING LEGISLATURE
BUT- THAT'S WHY WE SIGNED UP FOR
IT WE'RE NOT. ABOUT A
COMPLAINING ABOUT IT THAT'S OUR
JOB NOTHING ELSE IS JUMPING
ANOTHER BODY MAKING DECISIONS
THAT USURP AUTHORITY I JUST
CAN'TTHE PORTS THAT'S WHAT MY
ISSUE WITH THAT WITH THE WAY THE
BILLS RIGHT NOW WITH CHANGES I
THINK IT'S WORKABLE. BUT TO GIVE
AUTHORITY UP NO NO AT THE END OF
THE DAY. A COMPLAIN TO BE MADE
AT. THE LEGISLATURE EIGHTY OF US
IN HERE AND THAT'S WITH THE BIG
ISSUE I JUST CAN'T DO IT SO I
CAN'T SUPPORT THE BILL IN ITS
CURRENT FORM. MISS BONTA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER OUR COLLEAGUES I RISE AS
A CO AUTHOR OF AB TWO FIVE SEVEN
AND THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
PASADENA FOR CONTINUING TO
ADVANCE THIS IMPORTANT
DISCUSSION THE FAST RECOVERY ACT
CONTAINS IMPORTANT PROTECTIONS
FOR WORKERS IN THE FAST FOOD
INDUSTRY ACCORDING TO THE LABOR
CENTER AT UC BERKELEY THERE ARE
AN ESTIMATED FIVE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS WHO
WORKED IN THE INDUSTRY IN TWENTY
NINETEEN. WITH MOST EARNING
CLOSE TO MINIMUM WAGE AFTER THE
GREAT RECESSION AND THE COVERT
NINETEEN INDUCED RECESSION OUR
ECONOMY AND THESE JOBS ARE THE
SAME AS WHAT MANY OF US ON THE
ON THIS FLOOR MAY REMEMBER FROM
MY TEENAGE YEARS. 77% ARE OVER
THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN EIGHT OUT OF
TEN ARE PEOPLE OF COLOR SIX OUT
OF TEN ARE LATINO TWO THIRDS ARE
WOMEN THIS BILL DOESN'T
INHERENTLY SET MINIMUM FAST FOOD
RESTAURANT EMPLOYMENT STANDARDS
WHAT IT DOES IS REQUIRE A NEW
COUNCIL WITH THE AYE OUT WITHIN
DIR TO DO SO WITH MANDATED
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PUBLIC INPUT.
HOWEVER THE PROMISE OF
STRENGTHENED WORKER PROTECTIONS
WITHIN THE FRANCHISEE AND
FRANCHISOR INDUSTRY IS AN
INVESTMENT AND ECONOMIC FUTURE
OF OUR STATE INCREASES IN RENTAL
INCOME THE TO HIGHER TEST SCORES
BETTER EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES FOR
CHILDREN AND IMPROVEMENTS IN
CHILDREN'S HEALTH. ORDING TO
OTHER RESEARCH. INCREASES THE AS
THESE ALSO IN OUR ADULT MEN
HEALTH INCLUDING THE SIGNIFICANT
REDUCTION IN SUICIDE RATES. I'M
A STRONG PROPONENT OF GREEN
MINING AND BUILDING WEALTH
EQUITABLY FOR CALIFORNIANS.
ADDRESS HISTORICAL DIVESTITURE
IN BLACK AND BROWN COMMUNITIES.
I BELIEVE AB TWO FOUR SEVEN WILL
HELP US DO THAT BY STRENGTHENING
PROTECTIONS AGAINST WEALTH
EXTRACTION. FROM FRANCHISEES AND
WORKERS ALIKE THAT IS PERVASIVE
IN THIS INDUSTRY AS WRITTEN BY
GEORGE TALKING FASTER. MR CHAT
IN. FAST FOOD WORKERS WERE
ALWAYS ESSENTIAL AND THE
PANDEMIC HAS BROUGHT THAT MORE
INTO STARK RELIEF. AS THEY
CONTINUE TO SERVE OUR COMMUNITY
THROUGH A GLOBAL PANDEMIC. ALEX
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON AB TWO BY SEVEN. THANK
YOU RESPOND MYSTERY THIS. YOUR
RECORD. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS I RISE TODAY AS A
JOIN AUTHOR OF AB TWO FIFTY
SEVEN. THE FAST FOOD
ACCOUNTABILITY AND STANDARDS
RECOVERY ACT. A BILL URGENTLY
NEEDED TO EMPOWER AND PROTECT
OUR ESSENTIAL WORKERS WORKING AT
FAST FOOD RESTAURANTS MANY OF
THEM ARE VERY OWN CONSTITUENTS.
FOR THE PAST TWO YEARS OF THE
PANDEMIC. THIS CHAMBER HAS
HONORED THE WORK AND SACRIFICES
OF CALIFORNIA'S ESSENTIAL
WORKERS. IF WE FAIL TO PASS AB
TWO FIFTY SEVEN TODAY. WE TURN A
BLIND EYE TO MORE THAN HALF A
MILLION FAST FOOD WORKERS. IN
OUR STATE WHO REMAIN ON THE
FRONT LINES TO OUR COMMUNITIES.
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF THE
PANDEMIC CALIFORNIA'S FAST FOOD
WORKERS HAVE WAGED MORE THAN
THREE HUNDRED STRIKES. SOUNDING
THE ALARM ON UNSAFE WORKING
CONDITIONS AND TODAY IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO HEAR THEM.
TO DO SOMETHING FOR THESE
WORKERS WE CAN'T WRITE OFF.
THESE AS MERELY PUBLICITA STARTS
THESE STRIKES ARE INDICATIVE. OF
WORKERS REACHING THEIR BREAKING
POINT AND CHOOSING TO TAKE
ACTION. AND OF COURSE RISKING
RETALIATION BY THEIR EMPLOYER TO
IMPROVE THEIR SAFETY OUT WORK.
THESE WORKERS HAVE EXHAUSTED
NEARLY EVERY OPTION AVAILABLE TO
THEM. YET THE SYSTEM HAS FAILED
THEM. BUT WE SHOULD INFILL THEM
TODAY. THIS IS OUR OPPORTUNITY
TO DO SOMETHING FOR A GROUP.
HALF A MILLION AST FOOD WORKERS
THAT NEED OUR VOICE. THIS IS WHY
I WAS ELECTED. FOR THE TWO TO
REPRESENT THEM MANY OF THEM MY
OWN CONSTITUENTS AND THEY'RE NOT
TEENAGERS LIKE- THE MEMBER FROM
OAKLAND MENTIONED THEIR- THIRTY
YEAR OLD WOMEN. THAT ARE
PROVIDING FOR THEIR FAMILY
THROUGH THIS JOB AND NOT GET IT
NOT HAVING ALL THE RIGHTS THAT
THEY DESERVE IN THEIR WORK.
BRINGING WORKERS TO THE TABLE
THROUGH AB TWO FIFTY SEVEN IS
THE BEST WAY FOR REGULATORS TO
TAP THEIR FRONTLINE EXPERIENCES
TO CREATE BETTER STANDARDS FOR
THIS INDUSTRY GIVING WORKERS A
VOICE THROUGH AB TWO FIFTY SEVEN
IS THE BEST WAY TO EMPOWER
WORKERS WHO HAVE BEEN ORGANIZING
IN THE STATE FOR NEARLY NINE
YEARS. EMPOWERING OUR FAST FOOD
WORKERS TO THE TABLE. IS THE
BEST WAY TO HONOR AND
ACKNOWLEDGE THE SACRIFICES THEY
HAVE MADE AS A CENTRAL FRONT
LINE WORKERS THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. THANK YOU MISS REAVIS MISS
KOREA. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS- AS A
PRO JOINT AUTHOR AND FORMER
ACTUALLY MCDONALD'S EMPLOYEE
WHEN I WAS IN HIGH SCHOOL I RISE
IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR AB TWO
FIVE SEVEN THE FAST FOOD
ACCOUNTABILITY AND STANDARDS ACT
THERE ARE HALF A MILLION FAST
FOOD WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA YET
THEY ARE SOME OF THE LOWEST
PAID. AND LEAST PROTECTED
ESSENTIAL WORKERS IN OUR STATE
LIKE SO MANY SERVICE AND CARE
JOBS FAST FOOD WORKERS
PREDOMINANTLY DONE BY BLACK
LATINO AND IMMIGRANT WORKERS IN
THIS INDUSTRY 80% OF THE
WORKFORCE ARE PEOPLE OF COLOR
AND 60% ARE LATINOS. THE FRONT
LINE THESE FRONTLINE WORKERS
HAVE FACED DIRE CONDITIONS
DURING THE PANDEMIC WORKERS WERE
GIVING DOGGIE DIAPERS HAS FACED
MASS FORCED TO WORK SICK AND
EVEN FIRE WHEN THEY DEMANDED
BETTER COPE WITH SAFETY
PROTOCOLS THERE WAS AN ARTICLE
THAT JUST CAME OUT A FEW DAYS
AGO WHERE A FAST FOOD WORKER WAS
TOLD BY THEIR MANAGER EVEN IF
YOU TEST POSITIVE FOR COALBED
DON'T TELL ANYONE WEAR A MASK
AND COME TO WORK. FOR YEARS
CALIFORNIA FAST FOOD WORKERS
HAVE BEEN ADVOCATING FOR
IMPROVED CONDITIONS IN THEIR
INDUSTRY WHEN I WAS IN HIGH
SCHOOL AND I WORKED AT
MCDONALD'S I HAD THIRTY NINE
CENT CHEESEBURGERS THROWN AT ME
BECAUSE THEY WERE NOT AT THE
SATISFACTION OF THE CUSTOMER I
HAD MY LIFE THREATENED I MY
COLLEAGUES AND I WOULD HAVE TO
FACE THESE TYPES OF CONDITIONS
EVERY DAY WHETHER IN THE DRIVE
THRU OR WHETHER. INSIDE THE
RESTAURANT I TELL YOU FROM
EXPERIENCE THAT THESE WORKERS
ARE SOME OF THE HARDEST. WORKING
PEOPLE THAT I HAVE EVER WORKED
WITH. AND THE QUESTION SHOULDN'T
BE WHY IS A FAST FOOD WORKER
EARNING MORE THAN ANOTHER WORKER
IN ANOTHER INDUSTRY THE QUESTION
SHOULD BE WHY IS INCOME
INEQUALITY SO PREVALENT ACROSS
OUR NATION AND OUR STATE. THAT
DEMANDS THAT WE ACTUALLY DO
SOMETHING AND TAKE ACTION SO THE
PEOPLE CAN LIVE IN DIGNITY IN
THEIR OWN NEIGHBORHOODS IN THEIR
OWN COMMUNITIES. THIS
LEGISLATION CREATES A MECHANISM
TO RAISE OVERALL STANDARDS AND
PROTECTIONS TO THE FAST FOOD
INDUSTRY. THROUGH INPUT FROM
FRONTLINE WORKERS AND FAST FOOD
EMPLOYERS IF WE ARE TO ACHIEVE A
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL THEN WE MUST
FIND INNOVATIVE WAYS TO PROTECT
AND EMPOWER. THE HALF MILLION
FAST FOOD WORKERS IN OUR STATE
COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS CARRILLO. C. NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM MR HOLDEN YOU MAY
CLOSE. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
. YOU KNOW LET ME JUST SAY FIRST
OF ALL I APPRECIATE. THOSE WHO I
STOOD UP AND ENSURE THEIR
CONCERNS- I THINK THERE'S NOT
ONE CONCERN THAT WAS RAISED
MAYBE NOT SPOKEN OUT. THAT WE
HAVE NOT I HAVE NOT. HEARD AND
HAVE NOT GIVEN A COMMITMENT. TO
WORK TO ADDRESS. WE TALK ABOUT
CONTROL LEGISLATURE. AND SOMEHOW
WE'RE BY TAKING THIS ACTION
ABDICATING OUR RESPONSIBILITY. I
WOULD JUST ASK. YOU TO THINK AND
REFLECT. YOU KNOW WITH THEGAMBLING CONTROL COMMISSION.
WHAT DECISIONS ARE THEY MAKING
RIGHT NOW. YOU KOW WHAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC SUBSTANCES
CONTROL. WHAT DECISIONS ARE THEY
MAKING WHAT POWER HAVE YOU
ALREADY ADVOCATED FOR THEM. AND
HUNDREDS MORE. THEIR DECISIONS
ARE GOING TO BE OVERLOOKED. LIKE
THIS PARTICULAR COUNCIL TALK
ABOUT OVERSIGHT. YOU GOT MORE ON
THIS COUNCIL THEN YOU DO A
HUNDREDS OF OTHERS THE MANY OF
YOU MAY NOT EVEN KNOW WHAT
DECISIONS THEY'RE TAKING RIGHT
NOW AND WHAT POWERS THEY ARE
USING THAT YOU GAVE. AND
RIGHTFULLY SO. WE CAN'T MANAGE
IT ALL. WHEN YOU'RE TRYING TO DO
SOMETHING DIFFERENT TO ADDRESS
PEOPLE. WHO KEEP FALLING THROUGH
THE CRACKS. YOU'RE TRYING TO USE
THESE ARE FOLKS THAT THEY CAN'T
EVEN GET. PLACE BECAUSE OF THE
FRAGMENTED INDUSTRY. TO WHERE
THEY CAN ORGANIZE AND HAVE A
LABOR YOU. YOU DID. WHEN YOU
HAVE THAT PROTECTION YOU HAVE
SOMEONE TO MUSLIMS THE CITY
FRANCHISE OR YOU'RE NOT TREATING
ME RIGHT. I'M NOT GOING TO BE
WORKING IN AN ENVIRONMENT WITH A
PANDEMIC AND NOT HAVE ALL THE
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT THAT I NEED
TO DO MY JOB. AND BE HEALTHIER
SAID. SO WHAT WE DO. NORICK. WE
ALREADY KNOW THE HIERARCHY OF A
FRANCHISE OPERATION. FRANCHISE
ZORA AND WHOEVER ELSE. THEY SAY
JUMP. FRANCHISEE SAYS HOW HIGH.
THE WORKER IS CAUGHT BECAUSE OF
A FRANCHISEE. IS BEING TOLD WHAT
TO DO AND HOW TO DO IT OR WHAT
NOT TO DO. THE WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN TO THE WORKER. THIS IS
TRYING TO FILL THAT GAP. THIS IS
TRYING TO ADDRESS A COUPLE WEEKS
AGO WE CELEBRATE DR KING'S
BIRTHDAY. REMEMBER A TIME WHEN
PEOPLE WANTED TO WORK. BUT THEY
WANTED TO HAVE BASIC RIGHTS THEY
WANTED TO BE ABLE TO GO TO A JOB
AND BE PROUD. NOW I'M NOT GOING
TO SAY. THAT EVERY FRANCHISEE
AND EVERY FRANCHISE WORST
DYNAMIC. IS BAD. THERE ARE SOME
OUTSTANDING FRANCHISEES. I
TALKED TO ONE. BALTIMORE AND I
PLAN ON TALKING TO MORE. WEWERE
TALKING ABOUT THEIR EMPLOYEES AS
FAMILY AND I BELIEVE THEM. BUT
JUST UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE
OTHERS WHO CLEARLY ARE NOT. AND
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE TO STEP IN
AND CREATE A SYSTEM THAT AT
LEAST GIVE THEM A SHOT. ARE YOU
CUT OUT NO. WE MADE AMENDMENT
SAYS THAT IT COMES BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE. THE COMMITTEE WILL
HAVE A PUBLIC HEARING BICAMERAL
. WE'LL HAVE A HEARING WITH THE
PUBLIC WEIGHING IN. WILL HAVE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT THEY'LL
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW
AND DECIDE IF THEY FEEL
COMFORTABLE OR NOT. THEY CAN
WRITE A BILL AS A COMMITTED. BUT
WE'RE ALSO LOOKING AT EXTENDING
THE TIME FOR IT. IF THAT IS AN
AREA CONCERNING MEMBERS. I ASK
THAT YOU SUPPORT THIS BILL.
BECAUSE IT IS ABOUT FAIRNESS.
AND IT IS ABOUT BRINGING ALL THE
RESPONSIBLE PARTIES TO THE TABLE
TO COLLABORATE ON SOLUTIONS
THIRTY SECONDS WAS ALL THE. I
THINK THIS BILL MAKES A BIG
DIFFERENCE FOR A LOT OF FOLKS
OUT THERE. WHO MANY OF THEM. OR
FREE THE STEP OUT AND LET THEIR
VOICES BE HEARD BECAUSE THEY
HAVE SOMETHING TO LOSE. OTHER
JOB. RESPECT LAST RIVAL. AND
WITH THAT. CARCLUB THE ROLE. IT
IS NOT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL
CLOSER ALL. CHINA RICE FORTY ONE
KNOWS NINETEEN THAT MEASURE
PASSES. FILE ITEM FORTY EIGHT.
AB FOURTEEN TEN BY MR RODRIGUEZ
CORPORATE. SOME AGO FOURTEEN TEN
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ AND
ACTUALLY THE COMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENTS MISTER RODRIGUEZ.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS THIS BILL
IS THE RESULT OF CONVERSATION
I'VE HAD WITH CONSTITUENTS ABOUT
THE DISCONNECT BETWEEN HOMEOWNER
RIGHTS AND SOME HOME OWNER
ASSOCIATIONS. A. B. FOURTEEN TEN
SIX PROTECT HOMEOWNER RIGHTS BY
FIRST ENSURING THAT THOSE IN
CHARGE OF A CHOICE OF PROPER
ETHICS AND HARASSMENT TRAINING
NEXT MY BILL ADDRESSES SOMETHING
THAT HAS HAPPENED DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND NATURAL DISASTERS.
HOMEOWNERS IN MY DISTRICT AND
BEYOND MY DISTRICT HAVE BEEN
CHARGED FOR MINOR VIOLATIONS
WHEN DUBBING QUARANTINE ARE YOU
BACK WAITED DURING STATES OF
EMERGENCY THIS IS A COMMON SENSE
BILL. MEASURES TO UPHOLD
HOMEOWNER RIGHTS TO PROTECT ALL
PARTIES FROM HARM I'VE WORKED
EXTENSIVELY ON OPPOSITION
CONCERNS NOT COMMITTED TO
CONTINUE THAT WORK I RESPECT US
FOR A VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
RODRIGUEZ SHE NOTICED CASH BAIT
ON THE ITEM. CORPORAL. SARAH
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF. DESIRE TO
VOTE. WELL. CULTURAL TIE THE BUT
I FORTY NINE KNOWS FIFTEEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM FORTY
NINE ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE EIGHTY
ONE FOR COREY. SO MIDDLE FIVE
EIGHTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IRWIN AND ACTIVATING THE
CYBERSECURITY. MEASUREMENTS
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT AB FIVE
EIGHTY ONE THE CYBER SECURITY
MEASURE WILL REQUIRE THAT STATE
AGENCIES IMPLEMENT FEDERAL
STANDARDS ON COORDINATED
VULNERABILITY REPORTING. THIS
FUNCTION IS CRITICAL TO MAKING
SURE WE ADDRESS THE RISKS POSED
TO OUR CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
IN A TIMELY MANNER THANK YOU AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I GO.
THANK YOU MR ONE. SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ADAM
CORP LIBERAL. SERVER ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS THAT A VOTE. BLACKWELL
CLOSER TIDE ABOUT I SIXTY NINE
OH ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES.
THIS IS FILE ITEM FIFTY AB SEVEN
FORTY EIGHT BY MISS CARILLO
QUICKLY ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN
FORTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARILLO AND OTHERS AND
ACTIVATING THE PEOPLE HEALTH
MYSTERY- YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU
MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I AM SO
PROUD TO PRESENT SOME LITTLE
SEVEN FOUR EIGHT WHICH WOULD
REQUIRE CALIFORNIA'S MIDDLE AND
HIGH SCHOOLS HIGH SCHOOLS TO
DISPLAY A POSTER MAKING
INFORMATION AVAILABLE TO
STUDENTS ABOUT COMMON MENTAL
HEALTH RESOURCES WHAT TO LOOK
OUT FOR COPING STRATEGIES. AND
SCHOOL SIDE MENTAL HEALTH
RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO THEM EVEN
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC THE BI
ANNUAL CALIFORNIA HEALTHY KIDS
SURVEY FROM THE TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES NOTED THAT THERE HAS
BEEN AN INCREASE IN DEPRESSION
ANXIETY AND OTHER ADVERSE MENTAL
HEALTH SYMPTOMS AMONG CALIFORNIA
MIDDLE AND HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
SINCE TWENTY FIFTEEN THE SURVEY
ALSO NOTES THAT STUDENTS OF
COLOR ARE MORE LIKELY TO BE
AFFECTED THIS YEAR WE WILL
RECEIVE THE RESULTS OF THE FIRST
CALIFORNIA HEALTHY KIDS SURVEY
CONDUCTED IN TWENTY NINETEEN.
AND THE RESULTS ARE SURE TO BE
TROUBLING ESPECIALLY AFTER THE
PAST TWO YEARS OF THE PANDEMIC
AS STUDENTS COME BACK TO CAMPUS
NOW IS THE TIME TO OFFER
MEANINGFUL INTERVENTIONS AND
HELP THOSE THAT NEEDED TO GET
BACK ON TRACK MAKING OUR
STUDENTS TO WEAR WHAT TO LOOK
OUT FOR AND HOW TO ADVOCATE FOR
THEMSELVES TO SEEK HELP IS KEY
AND THAT IS WHAT THIS BILL SEEKS
TO DO TO ULTIMATELY ELIMINATE
THE STIGMA AROUND MENTAL HEALTH
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND HAS NO OPPOSITION. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
. THANK YOU MISS CARRILLO. C. NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
OR CALL THE ROLL. SERVER OF EVER
SPEND SATURDAY. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THEM. CLICK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIED OF I. SEVENTY NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES. WE ARE
GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY ON
FILE ITEMS. FIFTY ONE FIFTY TWO
AND FIFTY THREE. THAT BRINGS US. TO FIVE FIFTY FOUR THIS IS MR
LEVINE'S. AB. TWELVE TWENTY
SEVEN. CORRECT ASSEMBLY BILL
TWELVE TWENTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE IMMACULATE
ENERGY. MISCELLANEA MAIL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB TWELVE TWENTY SEVEN
WILL HELP MITIGATE CLIMATE
CHANGE AND REDUCE ENERGY USE BY
WORKING TO RAISE STANDARDS FOR
ENERGY EFFICIENT ROUGHS THESE
ENERGY EFFICIENT REFER ALSO
KNOWN AS COOL ROOFS AND ARE
DESIGNED TO REFLECT MORE
SUNLIGHT IN ABSORB LESS HEAT
THAN A STANDARD ROOF. WITH
WIDESPREAD USE URBAN HEAT
ISLANDS CAN BE REDUCED ACCORDING
TO A STUDY IN ENVIRONMENTAL
INTERNATIONAL URBAN POPULATIONS
ARE IN IT AT AN INCREASED RISK
OF A FAX FROM HEAT. AND HEAT
ISLANDS CAN BE ASSISTED WITH
INCREASESIN HEAT RELATED
MORTALITY BY REFLECTING MORE
SUNLIGHT IN ABSORBING LESS HEAT
THAN STANDARD ROOFS COOL ROOFS
LEAD TO MORE ENERGY CONSERVATION
AND CHORUS PROVIDE AN AVERAGE
YEARLY NEW SAVINGS OF ALMOST
FIFTY CENTS PER SQUARE FOOT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS LIVING.
SAYING NO MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION. ON THE ITEM CLERK
LITERAL. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT
OF THEM. ALL MEMBERS OF THE
CEREMONY. WELL. CLOSE ROLE TELL
YOU WHAT I FIFTY TWO KNOWS
EIGHTEEN. THAT MEASURE PASSES
THIS IS FILE ITEM FIFTY FIVE AB
THIRTEEN SIXTY NINE. CORKERY
SYMBOL THIRTEEN SIXTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENNETT NATALIE
THE PUBLIC CONTRACTS. MISTER
BENNETT YOU MAY OPEN. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN. AB THIRTEEN SIXTY
NINE MAKES MODIFICATIONS TO THE
STATE'S EXISTING BY CLEAN
PROGRAM ADDING INTERIOR
MATERIALS TO LIST MATERIALS FOR
WHICH THE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES MUST DEVELOP A MAXIMUM
ACCEPTABLE GLOBAL WARMING
POTENTIAL THE BILL ALSO ALLOWS
DGS TO UPDATE THE LIST OF
MATERIALS THAT THE BY COMING
CLEAN PROGRAM INCLUDES AND MAKES
CLEAR THAT INTERIOR MATERIALS
ADDED SHALL BE EVALUATED BASED
ON PRODUCT SPECIFIC GLOBAL
WARMING POTENTIAL. AB THIRTEEN
SIXTY NINE TAKES IN A PORTENT
STEP FORWARD IN STRENGTHENING
OUR BY CLEAN PROGRAM SO THAT WE
CAN MAKE PROGRESS TOWARDS OUR
MISSION'S GOALS AND MINIMIZE OUR
CARBON FOOTPRINT WITH EVERY
STATE FUNDED PROJECT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER BENNETT
SAY NO DISCLOSURE MADE ON THE
ADAM CLICK LIBERAL. ALL MEMBERS
FUNDS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS OF.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE I FIFTY ONE NO
SEVENTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
THIS IS FILE ITEM FIFTY SIX AB
FORTINO SIX BY MR LACKEY
CORPORATE SYMBOL FOURTEEN OH SIX
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LACKEY AND ACT
WITHIN THE LAW ENFORCEMENT ASIAN
POLICIES. MITCHELL ACTIVE. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS. GOAL
THIS BILL IS TO PREVENT STACKING
. CURRENTLY PEACE OFFICERS ARE
NOT REQUIRED TO CARRY THEIR
FIREARM. AND TASER ON SEPARATE
AREAS OF THE PERSON. THIS IS
LEAD TO UNNECESSARY CATASTROPHES
WHEN FIREARMS HAVE BEEN ACTUALLY
DISCHARGE IN PLACE OF A TASER.
THIS BILL AS A PROTECTIVE
MEASURE TO PREVENT FATALITIES BY
REQUIRING LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS TO CARRY THEIR TASER ON
THE OPPOSITE SIDE OF THEIR
PRIMARY WEAPON. WITH THIS
REQUIREMENT WE AIM TO PREVENT
FUTURE CALAMITIES BY SETTING UP
OFFICERS FOR SUCCESS. WHEN
ENTERING HIGH RISK SITUATIONS
WHERE DECISIONS ARE MADE AND
JUST A QUICK MOMENT. TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM HAYWARD I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTARY ON
WE CAN DRAW. WELL IT IS WORTHY
OF CONSIDERATION. FOR FUTURE
DISCUSSIONS ON BEST PRACTICES
THIS LEGISLATION WILL CODIFY
EXISTING PRACTICES THIS BILL IS
ENJOYED CONSENT STATUS THUS FAR
AND ASK YOUR RIVAL. THEY WERE
SLAPPED LACKEY MISTER COOPER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. MISTER SPEAKER
QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR SO THESE
ARE THE OPTIONS. THANK YOU A LOT
OF AUTHORS ARE WEARING SO THIS
THE OLD SAMBRO THE GUN BUILT ON
THEIR WAY THROUGH WEARING A
VEST. SO OBVIOUSLY SOME FARMS
ENOUGH FOR THE VEST. TASER SILVA
HOW DO WE RECONCILE THAT. THAT
WOULD BE A SECONDARY WEAPON. AND
SO WHAT WHAT WE WANT IS THE
STATION TO BE ON THE OPPOSITE
SIDE OF THEIR PRIMARY WEAPON.
IT'S JUST A SOMETIMES YOU'RE A
FIREARM ALSO ON INVEST. IN THE
MIDDLE OF BEST AND THAT'S IF YOU
LOOK AROUND YOU SEE OBVIOUSLY
NOT THESE PEOPLE A LOT OF LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT. YOUR POLICE AND
SHERIFFS AND ALL THE THIS
WEEKEND. AND MOST THE MEN AND
WOMEN WEAR VESTS BECAUSE A LOT
OF WE'RE GETTING. BACK ISSUES
THE GUN AWAY FROM THE GUN BILL
THESE DAYS SO. THE GUNS IN THE
CENTER THAT BEST AND THAT'S WHEN
TRYING TO GET THIS BILL WILL NOT
CONFLICT WITHOUT OPPORTUNITY FOR
THEM TO CARRY THEIR WEAPONS OKAY
PASSED. IT ON MY OWN TIME JUST I
MEAN WE HAD ONE INCIDENT WE KNOW
ABOUT- I CARRIED A GUN FOR A
LONG TIME THIRTY YEARS I CARE TO
TASER. AND IT'S. ONE OF THOSE
THINGS WERE- SO MESSED UP AND
DID MISTAKE. IT WAS A DUMB
MISTAKE- EVERYONE DOESN'T DO THE
- AND- I THINK WHEN YOU'RE OUT
THERE WORKING THAT'S- STREETS
AND DOING THAT IT'S- OFFICERS
WHERE THEY'RE SET UP. WHAT FEELS
MOST COMFORTABLE THEM. THOSE
LITTLE THINGS WERE THROWN OUT
BABY WITH THE BATH WATER- IT
JUST IT JUST CONCERNS ME WITH
THAT- SO A LOT OF FOLKS HAVE
DIFFERENT SET UPS FOR A VARIETY
OF REASONS AND- I'M NOT SURE IF
BECAUSE WE'VE HAD. ONE INCIDENT
THAT WAS THE INTENT ON TV BUT-
FOLKS GO DAY IN AND DAY OUT AND
USE BOTH THEIR WEAPONS AND NEVER
HAD THE ISSUE WITH THAT. I THINK
THIS IS A HORRIFIC MISTAKE- AND
I DON'T KNOW IF THIS IS A- THE
RIGHT BUILDER ACTUALLY FIX IT.
THANK YOU. SAYING NO OTHER
MEMBERS. SEEKING RECOGNITION. ON
THE ITEM. MR LACKEY YOU MAY
CLOSE. YEAH I'VE I WOULD- WITH
ALL DUE RESPECT TO. THOSE
REMARKS WERE JUST STATED I DON'T
THINK THAT THERE'S A CONFLICT.
AND NOW PUTTING THE TASER. ON
THE OPPOSITE SIDE OF THE PRIMARY
WEAPON I THINK IT'S- IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT I DON'T THINK IT
CONFLICTS. WITH PEOPLE CARRY
SECONDARY WEAPONS ELSEWHERE.
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO AVOID IS
THE STACKING. OF ONE DIRECTLY
BEHIND THE OTHER IT'S VERY VERY
EASY IT'S NOT JUST BEEN ONE
INSTANCE TO MORE THAN ONE. AND
THAT'S TOO MANY. AND RULE THIS
IS A VERY PREVENTABLE SITUATION
LET'S LET'S MAKE A PREVENTABLE I
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT. AND WITH
THAT QUIP LIBERAL. THERE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VISIBLE. ALL MEMBERS
OF. DESERVING. CLARK WELL.
CALDERON AND TALLY THE VOTE I
SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES. AVERAGE THIS IS FILE
ITEM FIFTY SEVEN. AB FOURTEEN
SIXTEEN CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY BILL
FOURTEEN SIXTEEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SANTIAGO AND OTHERS GOINGTO ELECTIONS MR SANTIAGO THANK
YOU SPEAKER AB FOURTEEN SIXTEEN
IS A COMMON SENSE SOLUTION THAT
WILL BRING TRANSPARENCY BALLOT
MEASURES AND PROVIDE VOTERS WITH
THE CRITICAL INFORMATION THEY
NEED TO CAST ABOARD THEIR VOTE
AND THEY WILL BE INFORMED THIS
BILL RE WOULD REQUIRE THE BALLOT
MEASURES. LABEL LABEL A
SHORTLIST OF WHO SUPPORT AND
WHOSE OPPOSITION FOR EVERY A
MEASURE. ANKARA SPEAKER I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NOVELS.
THANK YOU SANTIAGO IS RIVAS
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TODAY AS A
PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR OF AB
FOURTEEN SIXTEEN AND IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS LEGISLATION. IN
A TIME WHEN TRUST IN OUR
ELECTORAL PROCESS HAS WEEKEND
IT'S CRITICAL THAT WE RESTORE
VOTERS FAITH IN OUR ELECTIONS
AND DISCLOSE BALLOT MEASURE
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
RIVAL. THANK YOU MS RIVAS. C.
NOTATIONAL DISCUSSION ON THE
ITEM. CORPORAL. ALL MEMBERS
ROADS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OF THIS ADVENT. WELL CLOSE ROLE
. TALLY THE VOTE IS FIFTY THREE
KNOWS EIGHTEEN. THAT MEASURE
PASSES. THIS IS FILE ITEM FIFTY
EIGHT. AB FOURTEEN FORTY FIVE
INITIAL OF INCORPORATE SOME AGO
FOURTEEN FORTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEVINE ACCOLADES HOUSING
MR LEVINE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB
FOURTEEN FORTY FIVE REQUIRES A
COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENTS A
DELEGATE SUMMARIES OR THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT TO
CONSIDER AN EMERGENCY EVACUATION
ROUTE CAPACITY WILDFIRE RISK SEA
LEVEL RISE AND OTHER IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE. WHEN ALLOCATING
HOUSING NEED IN THEIR
METHODOLOGY FOR THE REGIONAL
HOUSING NEEDS ALLOCATION PROCESS
CLIMATE DISASTERS IN THE IMPACT
OF CLIMATE CHANGE ON OUR STATE
HAVE MADE PLACES UNSAFE TO LIVE.
WHAT CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE MAKES
IT PRONE TO FIRES HUMAN CAUSED
CLIMATE CHANGE IS CAUGHT FIRE TO
BE BIGGER AND MORE DESTRUCTIVE
THAN EVER BEFORE OF THE TWENTY
MOST DESTRUCTIVE WILDFIRES IN
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY FIFTEEN
HAVE OCCURRED SINCE TWENTY
FIFTEEN INCLUDING FIVE IN TWENTY
TWENTY INTO LAST YEAR. AN
ADDITIONAL FIRES SEVERE DROUGHT
IN PERIODS OF RECORD BREAKING
HEAT THE SCIENCE SHOWS US THAT
CLIMATE CHANGE WILL RESULT IN
GRADUAL AND PERMANENT RISING SEA
LEVELS POSING A SERIOUS THREAT
THE CALIFORNIANS FEEL LEVELS
ALONG THE CALIFORNIA COAST ARE
PROJECTED TO RISE ABOUT SIX
INCHES BY TWENTY THIRTY. AND AS
MUCH AS TEN FEET BY TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED COMPARED TO TWO THOUSAND
LEVELS. INCREASE RISK OF
FLOODING WILL AFFECT BUSINESSES
LOCAL ECONOMIES AND BOTH
HOMEOWNERS AND PEOPLE RENTING
HOMES WHO ARE LESS ABLE TO
PREPARE THE RESIDENTS FOR FLOOD
EVENTS UNFORTUNATELY AS OUR
STATE FACES A CLIMATE CRISIS IT
ALSO FACES A HOUSING CRISIS AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS MUST FACTOR
THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE DISASTERS
ON WHERE TO BUILD HOUSING WHILE
SEEKING TO EXPAND. THE SUPPLY OF
HOUSING UNITS THIS BILL WILL
ENSURE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT THE IMPENDING
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE AND
DISASTERS ON RISK TO RESIDENTS
WHEN PLANNING FOR ADDITIONAL
HOUSING. IN THEIR COMMUNITIES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS LEVINE
. C. NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
OUT OF THE CLUB THERE ALL. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE CEREMONY. ALL
MEMBERS WEARS OUT OF THEM. CLICK
WELL CLOSER ROLE ANTI THAT ICE
FIFTY FOUR KNOWS THIRTEEN. THAT
MEASURE PASSES HE IS FILE ITEM. FIFTY NINE. AB. FOURTEEN SIXTY
SEVEN FIVE MR BONTA S. CORRECT
ASSEMBLY GO FOURTEEN SIXTY SEVEN
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CERVANTES ANAK
LIVING STUDENT SAFETY. MISTER
MATIS THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
THE ROLE OF A SEXUAL ASSAULT
COUNSELOR ON A UNIVERSITY CAMPUS
IS TO PROVIDE STUDENT SURVIVORS
WITH ALL THE POSSIBLE OPTIONS
AVAILABLE TO THEM AND SUPPORT
WHATEVER DECISION THAT SURVIVORS
MAKE THESE CHOICES MAY EVEN
INCLUDE ACTION AGAINST THE
UNIVERSITY ITSELF THIS MEANS
THAT THOUGH THEY ARE ENTRUSTED
TO DO WHAT IS IN THE BEST
INTEREST FOR SURVIVORS. OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT COUNSELOR CAN BE
PLACED IN A POSITION OF HAVING
TO CHOOSE BETWEEN EIGHTEEN A
SURVIVOR AND FACING DISCIPLINARY
ACTION INCLUDING DISMISSAL WHEN
UNIVERSITIES MAINTAIN POLICIES
THAT HAMPER THE ABILITY OF A
SEXUAL ASSAULT COUNSELOR TO
PROVE TO OPERATE INDEPENDENTLY
THEY ENABLE A CAMPUS CLIMATE
THAT CONDONES SEXUAL VIOLENCE
AND SILENCES STUDENT SURVIVORS
AB FOURTEEN SIXTY SEVEN WILL
PROVIDE CLARITY TO SUCH
SITUATIONS BY CLEARLY
ESTABLISHING. THAT CAMPUS SEXUAL
ASSAULT COUNSELORS OPERATE
INDEPENDENTLY OF THE
UNIVERSITY'S TITLE NINE OFFICE.
THIS BILL ENSURES I CAMPUS
SEXUAL ASSAULT COUNSELORS HAVE
THE SUPPORT THEY NEED TO DO
THEIR JOB AND THEREFORE HAVE
BETTER TOOLS JUST TO SUPPORT
STUDENT SURVIVORS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
ABOUT. THANK YOU MISTER MARKS
SEEING NO DISCUSSION. OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM CLICK LIBERAL. SARVA. ALL MEMBERS UNDESERVEDLY. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ABOUT CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE VOTE I SAID I
SEVENTY NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE TO FILE ITEM EIGHTY TWO.
THIS IS FILE ITEM EIGHTY TWO.
ACR ONE TWENTY SEVEN BY DR WEBER
CORPORATION. ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE TWENTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KITA WEBER
RELATIVE TO PHYSICIAN
ANESTHESIOLOGISTS WEEK. DR WEBER
YOU MAY OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I AM HONORED TO PRESENT
ACR ONE TWENTY SEVEN WHICH
RECOGNIZES THE WEEK OF JANUARY
THIRTIETH THROUGH FEBRUARY FIFTH
AS PHYSICIAN ANESTHESIOLOGIST
WEEK. PHYSICIAN
ANESTHESIOLOGISTS ARE GUARDIANS
OF THEIR PATIENT SAFETY BEFORE
DURING AND AFTER SURGERY WITH
THE EXPERT ABILITY TO LEAD AND
NAVIGATE VITAL MOMENTS OF CARE.
THIS INCLUDES THE OPERATING ROOM
IN THE DELIVERY ROOM IN
INTENSIVE CARE UNIT IN PAIN
CLINICS AND DURING UNPRECEDENTED
TIMES SUCH AS A PANDEMIC. THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
ANESTHESIOLOGISTS HAS TAKEN
PROACTIVE STEPS TO PROMOTE
PATIENT SAFETY. AND INCREASE
EDUCATION ABOUT PAIN MANAGEMENT
SAFE OPIOID USE AND NON OPIOID
ALTERNATIVES TO PAIN MANAGEMENT
IN ORDER TO PROVIDE THE MOST
EXCELLENT CARE. PHYSICIAN LED
ANESTHESIOLOGY ANESTHESIA CARE
ALSO SAVE COSTS BY IMPROVING
PATIENT OUTCOMES AND SAVING
LIVES WHILE REDUCING MEDICAL
CONSULTATIONS UNNECESSARY TESTS
AND CANCEL SURGERIES DUE TO
MEDICAL REASONS. WITH ADVANCED
EDUCATION AND TWELVE TO SIXTEEN
THOUSAND HOURS OF TRAINING
BEFORE PRACTICING INDEPENDENTLY
PHYSICIAN ANESTHESIOLOGIST
ENSURE THE HIGHEST QUALITY SAFE
IT'S CARE AND PATIENT AND BEST
PATIENT OUTCOMES. AND ON A
PERSONAL NOTE THE
ANESTHESIOLOGIST FOR THOSE THAT
I WORKED MOST CLOSELY WITH BOTH
DURING RESIDENCY AND ALSO AS AN
ATTENDING. THEY NOT ONLY WE KEEP
MY PATIENTS WHO ARE IN LABOR AS
PAIN FREE AS POSSIBLE BUT IN
SURGERIES THEY ALWAYS CUT MY
PATIENTS ALIVE AND FOR THAT I
WILL BE ETERNALLY GRATEFUL. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
TO RECOGNIZE JANUARY THIRTIETH
THROUGH FEBRUARY FIFTH AS-
TWENTY TWENTY TWO S. PHYSICIAN. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
LOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR SPEAKING
COLLEAGUES I THINK. ARE CALLING
FROM SAN DIEGO THERE'S NO
EXCEPTION TO HAVING A DOCTOR IN
THE HOUSE AND JOIN IN
RECOGNIZING THE INCREDIBLE WORK
OF THE CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
ANESTHESIOLOGISTS THEY'VE BEEN
INCREDIBLE IN HELPING TO
ADVOCATE FOR NON PHARMACOLOGICAL
OPTIONS WITH RESPECT TO PAIN
MANAGEMENT AS WELL AS HELPING TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE A STRONG
PIPELINE OF HEALTH CARE WORKERS
AND FRONTLINE RESPONDERS FOR THE
FUTURE. GIVEN THE COST OF LIVING
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND I
JOIN AND ALSO RECOGNIZING THE
INCREDIBLE WORK. OF OUR FRONT
LINE RESPONDERS. THANK YOU MR
LOW. BUT CHOI IF YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU SPEAKER AND
THE MEMBERS DOCTOR ARE. YES OF
ALL OF OUR ONE OF THE AND- SO I
. THIS SO ACR ONE SO RECOGNIZE.
AND IS THIS SALAS AHA WORK BY
DESTINY ON ONE ON. S. WHAT. HIS
TRAINING AND THE LAW SOLDIER
THE- WILL WORK HOW HARD TO HIT
IS. FULL AND IF ALL OF SO IN
SURGERY ROOM SO FOR THE SO TO BE
- MOST COMFORTABLE AND NOT ALSO
CRUDE TO. SO WHETHER THAT OUT
THOUGHT TO BE OUR ENTIRE- BODY
HAS TO BE- A LAW. IT IS SEDATED
OR OF SUDDEN I LOCAL LAW OF. THE
LOCAL LOCAL- AND SEE. SHOULD BE
APPLIED TO A TO MOVE- MAKE DAHLE
PAYS THE LESS PAINFUL AND THE
AND LESS DANGER OF POST OVER
VERY CRITICALTWO SISTERS I
THOUGHT THE OF FINISHED NOW AND
- TO WOULD HAVE. GO THROUGH A
DAY AND- WE KNOW THAT THE HOUSE
HOW MANY- PEOPLE GO THROUGH A
DAY TYPE OF. THE PAYS AND CLOSE
AND IF SOLID ARE ONES SO- TO.
OUR MAINTAIN THE PAIN MANAGE.
DAS S. WE GET. NOT SO VERY
CRITICAL LAW WE ARE OF OUR
MAINTAINING ALL. AND THAT ALSO I
SEE THAT ORDER CHILDREN THIS-
WHEN ARE. TO THROUGH SECTION AND
IF THIS TO ARE THEY- AND TO MAKE
A THE- DELIVERY OF THE BABY SAFE
AND THAT AS- LAST PAID FOR AS
SOME POSSIBLE SO. RUN TO HEART
WHEN YOU RECOGNIZE THE WORK OF
THE SHE R. I THINK THAT THIS A
VERY APPROACH- TO RECOGNIZE YOUR
BILL HAUNTING. AND A SAFETY OF
THE PATIENT. ARE THROUGH THE SAW
ACR. ONE TWO SEVEN. AND ICU ON
VENTILATOR IS AN
ANESTHESIOLOGIST ARE THE MASTER
OF INTUBATION AND SO OFTEN TIMES
IT WAS AND IS THIS THE
ANESTHESIOLOGIST THAT RECALL
THAT. TO INTEGRATE THE SICKEST
OF THE SICK IS DURING OUR
PANDEMIC RISKING EXPOSING
THEMSELVES TO A VIRUS THAT WE
KNOW VERY LITTLE ABOUT. AND SO
WE SHOULD ALL BE EXTREMELY
GRATEFUL FOR NOT EVERYTHING THAT
THEY HAD DONE PRIOR TO THE
PANDEMIC BUT THE THINGS THAT
THEY WENT ABOVE AND BEYOND
DURING THE PANDEMIC FOR TAKING
CARE OF OUR SICKEST PATIENTS.
AND I ASK THAT THE FIRST ROLE BE
OPEN FOR COOPERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TO WHOEVER. MEMBERS
WITH THAT WE WILL OPEN THE ROLE
FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE ROAD. CO
AUTHORS ON ACR. ONE TWENTY
SEVEN. THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ROLE THERE ARE
SIXTY EIGHT CO AUTHORS AT A
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. YES HAVE IT THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. AND ON
BEHALF OF DOCTOR WHEREVER WE ARE
JOINED BY GUESTS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
ANESTHESIOLOGISTS PLEASE HOLD
YOUR APPLAUSE TILL THE END
MEMBERS. WE ARE JOINED BY DR
ANTONIO HERNANDEZ CONTE CSA'S
CHAIR DR EDWARD MARIANO CSA'S
PRESIDENT ELECT DR JEFF POPE
CSA'S PAST PRESIDENT AND FINALLY
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR MEGAN MAKE ME
LET'S WELCOME THEM TO THE
ASSEMBLY. FLOOR. MEMBERS BACK IN
REGULAR FILE ORDER. WE ARE AT
FILE ITEM SIXTY AB FIFTEEN OH
TWO BY MR BURKE CHIU CHIH. THE
CORPORATE SYMBOL FIFTEEN OH TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MURATSUCHI AND
OTHERS NATALIE THE HEALTH
FACILITIES MISTER MURATSUCHI
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TO PRESENT AB FIFTEEN OH TWO
TOGETHER WITH MY JOIN AUTHOR THE
CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY HEALTH
COMMITTEE. WE'VE BEEN WORKING
HARD THIS PAST A YEAR AND A HALF
TO MAKE THIS BILL UNWORKABLE
BILL THIS BILL SEEKS TO FIX A
BROKEN STATE LICENSING SYSTEM
FOR NURSING HOMES OPERATING IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THE
STATE AUDITOR ALONG WITH NEWS
MEDIA OUTLETS MOST RECENTLY IN
THE CALMATTERS THE SACRAMENTO
BEE AND OTHERS HAVE DOCUMENTED
FOR YEARS HOW THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH IS
ALLOWING UNLICENSED NURSING
HOMES. INCLUDING SOME THAT ARE
PART OF THE LARGEST NURSING HOME
CHAIN IN OUR STATE TO OPERATE
EVEN AFTER HAVING THEIR LICENSE
APPLICATION REJECTED. THIS BILL
STANDS FOR A SIMPLE COMMONSENSE
PROPOSITION NO ONE SHOULD BE
ALLOWED TO OWN AND OPERATE A
NURSING HOME IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WITHOUT A LICENSE. WE
HAVE SEEN DURING THIS PANDEMIC
HOW NURSING HOME RESIDENTS ARE
AMONG THE MOST VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS WE NEED TO FIX THIS
BROKEN STATE LICENSING SYSTEM IN
ORDER TO PROTECT OUR MOST
VULNERABLE SENIORS. THAT IS WHY
THIS BILL IS SPONSORED BY THE
CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES FOR NURSING
HOME REFORM AND SUPPORTED BY THE
A RP. THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE
FOR RETIRED AMERICANS CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LONG TERM CARE
MEDICINE S. C. ARE YOU
CALIFORNIA AND MANY OTHERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MURATSUCHI DR
WHAT. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I
RISE AS THE CROWD JOIN AUTHOR OF
THIS BILL- IT IS A WORK- THAT WE
SPEND A FAIR AMOUNT OF TIME ON
AND- AND I THINK IT'S A IT'S AN
IMPORTANT MISSION- PART OF WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS PROTECT.
SOME OF THE MOST VULNERABLE
PEOPLE IN OUR SOCIETY THOSE WHO
MANY CASES DON'T HAVE A VOICE
FOR THEMSELVES. THIS WAS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT FOR US TO
BE ABLE TO MAKE SURE THAT. THE
FACILITIES THAT THEY LIVE IN ARE
LICENSED APPROPRIATELY. AND THEY
CAN HAVE THE SAFETY AND-
PROTECTIONS THAT THEY NEED TO
LIVE THE REST OF OUR LIVES AND
THE HIGHEST QUALITY. THEY CAN.
BE SEEN TOO MANY. PERISH IN
NURSING HOMES DURING COBIT. OR
SEEN ANOTHER WAVE OF IT NOW-
THEIR FRAGILE POPULATION. I
THINK THERE'S- CULTURES THAT
BELIEVE THAT- AND I PERSONALLY
BELIEVE IT THAT WE ARE OFTEN
JUDGED BY HOW WE- TAKE CARE OF
THOSE WHO ARE THE MOST
VULNERABLE AMONG US I THINK THIS
IS ONE OF THOSE EFFORTS AND- I.
R. DRIVE UP. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU DOCTOR WHAT. C. NOTATIONAL
DISCUSSION ON THE ADAM. QUIBERON. DESIRABLE ALL MEMBERS WILL.
DESIRABLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE VOTE. CLICK WELL. CULTURAL
TIE VOTE HIGHS FORTY SEVEN KNOWS
TWELVE THAT MEASURE PASS.
MEMBERS WE HAVE. MANY FIND ITEMS
STILL TO TAKE UP TODAY BUT AT
THIS TIME WE ARE GOING TO
ENTERTAIN VOTE CHANGES. AND WE
WILL MOVE TO TAKE UP A COUPLE OF
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY TO HAVE
ANY VOTE CHANGES MEMBERS. START
YES THIS IS OUR QUE HAN. CAN YOU
. CHECK OUT THE CHANGE AB
FOURTEEN TEN YES TO NONVOTING.
WELL CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BALCONY HANNAH SOME WIGGLE
FOURTEEN TEN I TO NOT LOADING.
THANK OF AMERICA HAVE. ANY
ADDITIONAL VOTE CHANGES FROM THE
FLOOR. C. NINE MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE TO TAKE UP A
COUPLE OF ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY
AT THIS TIME AND I WOULD ASK
THAT. YOU REMAIN IN YOUR SEATS
AND TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
OF THE FLOOR IF NEED BE. WE ASK
THAT YOU GIVE YOUR RESPECTFUL
ATTENTION TO YOUR COLLEAGUES AT
THIS TIME. WE ARE AT
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. AGAIN WE
HAVE ITEMS REMAINING TO BE TAKEN
UP THIS AFTERNOON. THE FOLLOWING
MEMBER SABRINA PRIOR PERMISSION
TO SPEAK ON A GERMAN IN MEMORY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN. YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
IN MEMORY AND MEMBERS PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS FOR TAKER
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS SOMETIMES A
PERSONALITY COMES ALONG WHO
BECOME SYNONYMOUS WITH THE PLACE
IN WHICH THEY LIVE- I HAVE THE
HONOR OF REPRESENTING LOS FELIS
IN EAST HOLLYWOOD. AND WE HAVE A
LOT OF BIG PERSONALITIES IN THAT
AREA AND A LOT OF. LOCATIONS
THAT PEOPLE KNOW ALL AROUND THE
WORLD WELL WE JUST LOST ONE OF
THOSE PERSONALITIES A FEW WEEKS
BACK. TODAY I RISE SADLY IN THE
MEMORY OF A LOS ANGELES I CON
MARTY ROBERTS. MARTY WAS BORN IN
NEW YORK CITY IN NINETEEN THIRTY
TWO AND MOVED TO MOVE TO LOS
ANGELES IN NINETEEN SEVENTY HE
MET HIS WIFE PIANIST AND SINGER
ELAINE WHO WAS IN NEED OF A
DRUMMER. IN JUST FOUR MONTHS
THEY WERE MARRIED AND LAUNCH
THEIR LOUNGE ACT MARTY IN A LANE
THEY PLAYED THE MELODY ROOM ON
THE SUNSET STRIP. THEN TO LOS
FELIS AT MICHAEL'S WHICH LATER
BECAME THE DERBY OF VERY FAMOUS
LANDMARK AND THEN TO THE
DRESSING ROOM ONE OF THE PLACES
THAT I HAVE BEEN VSITING SINCE
I MOVED O LOS ANGELES IN
NINETEEN NINETY TWO. MARTINO
LANE PLAYED THE DRESSING ROOM
ROOM FOR NEARLY FORTY YEARS THEY
APPEARED IN A TOM PETTY VIDEO
COLLABORATED WITH THE RED HOT
CHILI PEPPERS BASSIST FLEA AND
ENTERTAINED COUNTLESS DURING
THEIR SETS THREE CIRCA SIX
NIGHTS A WEEK THEY WERE A STAPLE
OF LOS FELIS. FANS WOULD VISIT
VISIT MARTY ONLY FROM AROUND THE
WORLD EVEN FRANK SINATRA VISITED
THEM AT A SHOW IN PALM SPRINGS
WHERE MARTY SAYING FRANK SINATRA
SONGS RIGHT BACK AT HIM. THEY
EVEN HAD A VERY WELL KNOWN CAMEO
IN THE MOVIE SWIMMERS. IF YOU
HAVEN'T SEEN IT I HIGHLY
RECOMMEND IT AND PLEASE LOOK FOR
MARTY. IN THAT FILM BECAUSE FROM
THAT ERA FROM THAT PLACE. HE WAS
A FIXTURE. MARTY'S LOS HAS BEEN
FELT PROFOUNDLY IN LOS FELIS
MARTY WOULD CALL U. K. TRADING
POST OWNER AT ALL TIMES OF NIGHT
AND DAY AND SUGGEST IDEAS FOR
HIS T. CUSTOM MADE T. SHIRT THAT
HE SELLS US AT U. K. REFERS TO
HIS SAYINGS AS MARTY ISMS AND
ONE OF HIS FAVORITES IS SMILING
IS FREE LOOK FOR THAT ONE ON A
SHIRT SOON. I ASK THAT WE THINK
OF HIM FONDLY SMILE WHEN WE
THINK OF HIM IN A LANE PLEASE TO
CHECK OUT THE CAMEO IN SWINGER.
AND LET'S BE PROUD TO ADJOURN
TODAY IN HIS MEMORY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS FRIEDMAN. AND
DOCTOR CHOI YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR GERMAN IN MEMORY. MEMBERS I
RISE TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY
ALL OF ALL VILLA PARK A CITY
COUNCILMAN WILLIAM BILL NOT OF
CERTAIN. BILL AND A HAS A FAMILY
RESIDED IN VILLA PARK CALIFORNIA
AND NEARLY FORTY YEARS. MISTER
NELSON ARE SADLY PASSED AWAY ON
JANUARY FOURTEENTH OF TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY TWO AT THE AGE
OF EIGHTY THREE. DILLON NELSON
WAS BORN ON JUNE TWENTY SECOND
NINETEEN THIRTY EIGHT IN PULASKI
TENNESSEE IS A PASSION FOR
PUBLIC SERVICE UP AGAIN WHEN HE
SERVED IN THE U. S. UP THERE FOR
SO FROM. NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE TO
NINETEEN SIXTY UPON HIS SOME
HONORABLE DISCHARGE. ESTRUTH HAS
SHUT EDUCATION COMPLETING A BA
IN ECONOMICS SO FROM CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY DOMINGUEZ HILLS HE
CONTINUED- HIS CELL EDUCATION AT
THE USC EARNING ON M. B. A. BILL
NELSON WAS OF THAT TO SERVING
THE PUBLIC I IN MANY ELECTED
AND- APPOINTED THE POSITIONS OF
INCLUDING YOUR FELLOW PARKS CITY
COUNCILMAN OF THE LOMPOC MAYOR.
AS CALIFORNIA'S DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION BOARD MEMBER- CA
ASSOCIATION ABA PUBLIC. CEMETERY
A BOARD MEMBER PHILLIP PARKER
COMMUNITY SERVICE FOUNDATION
TREASURER CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF REALTORS OF MEMBER ORANGE
COUNTY OF GRAND JURY ASSOCIATION
BOARD MEMBER PRIOR TO HIS LIFE
IN PUBLIC SERVICE. A LOT WORK
THERE FOR MORE THAN TWENTY FIVE
YEARS AS A FINANCIAL
PROFESSIONAL WITH THE ARTICLE
LET'S LET IT GO. RICHFIELD THE
COMPANY AND THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA GAS COMPANY. IS
DEDICATED HIS LIFE TO HIS SON
LOVING WIFE FOR NEARLY FIFTY
YEARS YOUR LAW MAY NELSON WHO
SADLY FOLLOWED HIM IN DEATH. SIX
DAYS LATER. BILL AND- YOU LAW
OUR SURVIVE THE BY SELF CHILDREN
KIM TOLD FILL. AND THE BREAD.
FIVE AGRANT. AND THE- GREAT
GREAT GRANDCHILDREN HE IS ALSO
SURVIVED THE BY FOUR SIBLINGS WE
WILL MISS HANS HERMANN BILL
NELSON GREATLY WE ORDERS CHERRY
SHE HANDLE REMEMBER HISSELF GOOD
CHARACTER. LOVE OF SURVEY ARE
AND A PASSION SERVE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DR CHOI. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SALAS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
. FOR YOUR A GERMAN IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TODAY AND TO SPEAK IN THE
MEMORY OF DAVID MARQUIS A
VETERAN OF VIETNAM IN A LOCAL
LEADER FROM CITY OF MCFARLAND.
THEY WAS BORN ON DECEMBER
SEVENTEENTH NINETEEN FORTY FOUR
DREW BIRDS THEY BORKI SENIOR AND
REBEKAH WORKING IN PENNSYLVANIA
. DAVE GREW UP IN CHESTER
PENNSYLVANIA FOR ALL OF HIS
CHILDHOOD. HE ONLY LAUGHED WHEN
HE FELT HIS DUTY TO HIS COUNTRY
HAD CALLED HIM HE LISTED IN THE
UNITED STATES NAVY IN NINETEEN
SIXTY FOUR. AT THE START OF THE
VIETNAM WAR. THERE WAS AN
AVIATION ELECT FOR ELEKTRISCHE
IN THE MAYBE PART OF THE
SQUADRON CALLED HEAVY ATTACK.
TESTING AND WORKING WITH CUTTING
EDGE INFRARED TECHNOLOGY. HE
BRAVELY SERVED HIS COUNTRY AND
TELLS DISHONORABLE DISCHARGE IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE. DURING
DAVE'S TIME SERVING IN THE NAVY
HE WAS THE RECIPIENT OF NUMEROUS
AWARDS OF ACCOMMODATIONS. FOR
HIS OUTSTANDING PERFORMANCE AND
COURAGEOUS EFFORTS AND THESE
INCLUDED THE NATIONAL DEFENSE
SERVICE MEDAL THE GOOD CONDUCT
MEDAL THE MERITORIOUS UNIT
COMMENDATION. THE VIETNAM CIVIL
ACTION AWARD AND THE VIETNAM
RIBBON OF GALLANTRY. AFTER
LEAVING THE NAVY DOES THEY BUILT
A WONDERFUL LIFE FOR HIMSELF HE
STARTED HIS CIVILIAN LIFE IN SAN
FRANCISCO WHEN HE MET THE LOVE
OF HIS LIFE SHARON. AND THEY WED
IN MARCH OF NINETEEN SEVENTY
THREE. TOGETHER THEY SURE FORTY
EIGHT YEARS OF LOVE AND RAISE
THEIR FOUR CHILDREN. MICHELLE
DAVID KATHERINE AND MATTHEW.
MCFARLAND DAY WAS INCREDIBLY
ACTIVE MEMBER OF THE COMMUNITY.
HE WAS A MEMBER OF THE MCFARLANE
LIONS CLUB VETERANS PLANNING
COMMITTEE. CHAIR OF THE FOOD
DISTRIBUTION IN THE PARLANCE.
AND MANY OTHER EVENTS FOR THE L.
DEAR TO HIS HEART IN FACT
MEMBERS IS HOW I CAME TO KNOW
DAVE. WAS THROUGH IS A LOT AT
THE LIONS CLUB IN A LOT OF THE
WORK THAT HE DID LOCALLY. THANK
YOU OF ONE OF THESE INDIVIDUALS
THAT WOULD HAVE A STRONG
PERSONALITY. AND ALWAYS TOLD ME
SAID RUDY. I DON'T SUPPORT ANY
DEMOCRATS WHAT I SEE HERE YOU'RE
DOING STUFF HERE AND I SUPPORT
YOU. HE WAS ONE OF THOSE TYPE OF
INDIVIDUALS- AND- HE HAD COME
SOAP. FROM THE SPECTRUM OF BEING
SKEPTICAL AT FIRST GOT ELECTED
THAT EVENTUALLY AND TWENTY
EIGHTEEN I SELECTED THEM TO BE
VETERAN OF THE YEAR FOR THE
THIRTY SECOND ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
BECAUSE OF HIS COMMITMENT TO
PEOPLE MAKING A DIFFERENCE. FOR
THE PEOPLE OF MCFARLAND AND THE
CENTRAL VALLEY YEAH HIS FAMILY
WAS THE CENTER OF HIS UNIVERSE
AND HE TREATED ALL THOSE WHO
ENTERED HIS LIFE LIKE A LIFELONG
FRIEND THEY WOULD DO ANYTHING TO
HELP THOSE IN A TIME OF THE- DAY
PASSED AWAY ON TUESDAY JANUARY
EIGHTEENTH. SURROUNDED BY THOSE
HE LOVED THE MOST. HE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE SHARON A
BORKI. DAUGHTERS MICHELLE AND
KATHARINE AND SONS DAVID AND
MATTHEW. AS WELL AS A BROTHER.
JAMES WORKING AND WIFE LYNN
BORKI OF PENNSYLVANIA. AND
SISTER MARIE. AT PENNSYLVANIA
HIS SISTER REBECCA- OWN SIN AND
HUSBAND. OF WISCONSIN. AND
SISTER AND HARVISON OF ALASKA.
MEMBERS AFTER WE ADJOURNED IN
HIS MEMORY TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER SALAS. THANK
YOU MEMBERS. PLEASE READ THE
NAMES OF THE DEATHS REPORT IN
THE JOURNAL ALL REQUEST RETURN
MEMORYWILL BE DEEMED READ AND
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
OKAY
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO RESUME
TAKING UP. A HANDFUL OF ITEMS.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
BACK IN THE FILE TO FILE ITEM
FIFTY TWO. FILE ITEM. FIFTY TWO.
THANK YOU MEMBERS THIS IS FILE
ITEM FIFTY TWO AB ONE THOUSAND
ONE FIVE MS GARCIA AND THE CLERK
WILL READ. A. B. ASSEMBLY BILL
ONE THOUSAND ONE BY SIMPLY
REVERSING A GARCIA AND OTHERS AN
ACTOR LIVING IN TO THE
ENVIRONMENT. MS GARCIA. THANK
pYOU I AB ONE THOUSAND ONE IS
ABOUT BETTER PROTECTING
FRONTLINE AND OVERBURDENED
COMMUNITIES FROM NEGATIVE ERAM
TAX. CURRENTLY WHEN WE DO THINK
LIMITATION- BUT IT'S NOT ALWAYS
NUMBER YOU DO NOT HAVE TO DO IT
IN THE IMPACTED COMMUNITY IT
COULD ACTUALLY BE DONE ANYWHERE
IN THE WORLD A LOT OF TIMES. AND
OFTENTIMES WE DO DO MITIGATIONS
COMMUNITIES BUT ON OCCASION WE
DON'T AND WE DO THEM ALL OVER
THE WORLD THIS BILL IS SIMPLY
SAYING THAT IT WE HAVE A KNOWN
OVER BURDEN COMMUNITY THAT HAS
AIR QUALITY ISSUES. THAT WE WILL
MAKE SURE THAT THE MITIGATION
HAPPENS IN THAT SAME COMMUNITY
AS I THINK IS LIVING UP TO THE
IDEA OF JUSTICE AND EQUITY FOR
THESE COMMUNITIES INSURING THAT
IT WE KNOW THAT THEY AREN'T
HEALTHY AT THEIR LIVES ARE BEINGHER SHORT THAT THEY'RE ENDING UP
IN THE E. R. BECAUSE I HAVE
ASTHMA OR OTHER RESPIRATORY TAX.
THAT WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE OKAY
WITH ADDING MORE BURDEN ON WHEN
A CONSPECIFIC LEAD TO AIR
QUALITY THIS BILL HAS BEEN
NARROWED TO TRY TO ADDRESS THE
OPPOSITION CONCERNS- AND THEY
HAVEN'T BEEN TOTALLY WILLING TO
COME TO THE TABLE BUT I AM
PRAGMATIC. IN TRYING TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE BEING FAIR TO
EVERYBODY AND I WELCOME THEM TO
THE TABLE AS THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
GARCIA. MS REYES YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AS A CO AUTHOR OF THIS
BILL I RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
TEN ZERO ONE. WE KNOW THAT THE
IMPACTS AND EFFECTS OF POLLUTION
ARE NOT DISTRIBUTED EQUALLY. LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
OFTEN FACE THE BRUNT OF AIR AND
WATER TOXICS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. WE NEED TO DO MORE
TO INCORPORATE ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE PRINCIPLES AS PART OF
THE STATE'S MITIGATION SO THAT
OUR CONSTITUENTS DON'T CONTINUE
TO PAY THE COST OF. DIRTY AIR
AND WATER. THIS BILL WILL
REQUIRE MITIGATION MEASURES IF
THEY INCLUDE COMPENSATION FOR
ADVERSE ENVIRONMENTAL EFFECTS TO
MITIGATE THE NEGATIVE IMPACTS
AND EFFECTS OF POLLUTION. IN
IMPACTED DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. WE NEED TO ENSURE
THAT THOSE WHO ARE MOST IMPACTED
BY POLLUTION ARE RECEIVING THE
BENEFITS OF MITIGATION MEASURES.
OR ELSE. THEY WILL CONTINUE TO
PAY. AND CAN YOU TO KEEP PAYING
THE PUBLIC HEALTH COSTS OF
BREATHING DIRTY AIR AND DRINKING
DIRTY WATER. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS- THANK YOU
ADDRESS SEEING NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM
. THIS GARCIA YOU MAY CLOSE IF
YOU WISH. WITH THAT CARPOOL
FEDERAL. IS THAT A VOTE ALL
MEMBERS WILL DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE CEREMONY.
ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ALL. TALLY THE
VOTE HIGHS FORTY ONE. THOSE
TWENTY TWO- THAT MEASURE PASSES.
OKAY MEMBERS WE ARE BACK IN
REGULAR FILE ORDER. REGULAR FILE
ORDER THIS IS. FILE ITEM SIXTY
ONE FILE ITEM SIXTY ONE.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN OH FIVE BY
MR RODRIGUEZ SAID THE
CORPORATION. ASSEMBLY GOAL
FIFTEEN OH FIVE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RODRIGUEZ AND ACT LIVING
A PUBLIC FOR SECONDARY EDUCATION
MISTER RODRIGUEZ MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB FIFTEEN OH FIVE WOULD
REVENGE THE FACULTY OBLIGATION
NUMBER FONT IN CALIFORNIA
COMMITTEE COLLEGES. THE FINEST
OF MR FLOOR TO THE MINIMUM
NUMBER OF FULL TIME FACULTY EACH
COMMUNITY COLLEGE MISSED OUT.
THE PHONE WILL DEVELOP TO ENSURE
COLLEGES AT A MINIMUM INCREASE
THEIR NUMBER OF FULL TIME
FACULTY WORKERS IN THE
PROPORTION TO THE GROWTH IN FULL
TIME EQUIVALENT STUDENTS.
CURRENTLY ALL BUT TWO OF THE
SEVENTY TWO COMMITTEE COLLEGES
DISTRICTS ARE OVER THE PHONE AND
IN SOME CASES BY HUNDREDS OF
FACULTY BY RETENTION THE FUND WE
CAN ENSURE FUTURE INVESTMENTS IN
FULL TIME FACULTY RESULT IN
ACTUALLY HIRING NEW FULL TIME
FACULTY ARE STRUCK OUT FOR YOU.
I WROTE. THANK YOU MISTER.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. CORPORAL.
DISARMAMENT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLARK WELL. ZERO
AND TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY FOUR
NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES
THIS IS FILE ITEM SIXTY TWO
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX THIRTY ONE BY
MR BLOOM THE CORPORATE ASSEMBLY
BILL SIX THIRTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM AN ACCOLADE
IN ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES MISTER
BLOOM EMAIL THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS LAST YEAR EIGHTY
SIX THIRTY ONE WITH A CONSENT
ITEM BUT WAS PLACED ON THE
INACTIVE FILE DUE TO THE- NOW
INFAMOUS TWELVE BILL LIMIT. AB
SIX THIRTY ONE SIMPLY EXTENDS
THE EXISTING EXEMPTION GIVEN TO
NONPROFIT LIVE STAGE THEATERS
TO. NOW INCLUDE NONPROFIT
CULTURAL FILM EXHIBITION
COMPANIES IN CALIFORNIA ALLOWING
THEM TO SERVE ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGES. SINCE THE PANDEMIC
BEGAN NONPROFIT CULTURAL FILM
EXHIBITIONS. USER THE THEATERS
THAT SHOW HUMPHREY BOGART- BUT
THE AND WE KNOW THAT THESE-
THEATERS HAVE TAKEN A HIT
FINANCIALLY SO IT SB SIX THIRTY
ONE SIMPLY HELP TO MAKE UP FOR
SOME OF THAT LOST REVENUE BY
WITH THE SALE OF ALCOHOLIC
BE SUCCESSFUL AFTER REOPENING I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS PERU. SAY NO
DISCUSSION OF A ON THE OTHER.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ESERVER MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS ARE DESIRABLE.
CLICK WELL. CLOSE ROLE AND TELL
A VOTE HIGHS SIXTY SIX. NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES. AND THIS IS
FILE ITEM SIXTY THREE AB TWELVE
OH EIGHT BY MISTER TECH FOR
COREY ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE OH
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING
ACCOLADES OF UNCLAIMED PROPERTY
MISTER K. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER IN TWENTY NINETEEN THE
STATE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE
ANNOUNCED THAT THEY WERE HOLDING
ON TO MORE THAN FORTY EIGHT
MILLION UNCLAIMED PIECE OF
PROPERTY WORTH OVER NINE BILLION
DOLLARS. AB TWELVE AWAIT
STREAMLINES THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S PROCESS FOR THAT
CALIFORNIANS CAN MORE EASILY
RECLAIMED THE PROPERTY WHICH IS-
TO THEM THE BILL REQUIRES LESS
DOCUMENTATION FOR CLAIMS UNDER
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS ALLOWS
ELECTRONIC SUBMISSION OF ALL
DOCUMENTS IN ALLOWS FOR DIRECT
DEPOSIT THE BILL'S ENJOYED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FRONT. THANK
YOU MISTER TANK. SEEING NO
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION ON
THIS ITEM. FOR CORPORAL. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS AND VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF THE. CLARK
WELL CLOSE THE ROLE AND TELL YOU
THE I. SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS A FEW
QUICK ANNOUNCEMENTS. I SEE OUR
COLLEAGUE CHAD MAYES HERE
SELLING THEIR MAYES
CONGRATULATIONS ON THE BIRTH OF
YOUR BEAUTIFUL DAUGHTER. WE ALSO
HAVE A COUPLE OF. UPCOMING
BIRTHDAYS ASSEMBLY WOMAN MIA
BONTA JANUARY TWENTY SIX WAIT.
THE UPCOMING THAT'S PASSED. I
HOPE YOU ENJOYED IT AS MUCH AS-
HAPPY BIRTHDAY. HE WAS ABSENT
LAST WEEK SO. ACTUALLY IT OFFICE
WAS READ THAT PART BUT- HAPPY
BIRTHDAY THIS BONTA. AND
ASSEMBLY WOMAN BOERNER HORVATH.
BIRTHDAY IS TOMORROW HAPPY
BIRTHDAY ASSEMBLY WOMAN.
MEMBERS
WE ARE BACK ON THE FILE. WE ARE
READ FILE ITEM SIXTY FOUR
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY BY MISTER
KALRA CORKERY. ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA
AND ACCORDING TO THE ENVIRONMENT
. MISTER KALRA THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB THIRTY
AFFIRMS THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS
HAVE ACCESS. EVASION INTO
EXISTING POLICIES REGARDING
ACCESS TO THE OUTDOORS
ESPECIALLY THE COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE OR HAVE STARKLY BEEN NATURE
DEPRIVED. WELL NATURE IS ALWAYS
BEEN ARRESTED FOR PEOPLE ACROSS
MANY BACKGROUNDS THE PANDEMIC IS
HIGHLIGHTED INEQUITIES IN
ACCESSING CLEAN AND SAFE OUTDOOR
SPACES AND IN WORST CASE
SCENARIOS THE LACK OF ACCESS TO
THESE PLACES ALL TOGETHER. BEING
ABLE TO ACCESS THE MANY BENEFITS
OF NATURE IS NECESSARY FOR NOT
ONLY MENTAL AND PHYSICAL HEALTH
BUT THE OVERALL WELL BEING OF
PEOPLE. AS THE DESTRUCTION OF
NATURE ACCELERATES AT
UNPRECEDENTED RATES DUE TO
CLIMATE CHANGE OTHER FACTORS.
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES WILL
CONTINUE TO BEAR MORE OF THE
NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES. THIS BILL
PUTS ACCESS TO THE OUTDOORS
FRONT AND CENTER. AND ENSURES
THAT WE HAVE A DIFFERENT MORE
INCLUSIVE APPROACH. AS TO WHO
CAN EXPERIENCE NATURE AND ITS
BENEFITS. BY ADOPTING AB THIRTY
CALIFORNIA SETS AN IMPORTANT
EXAMPLE FOR THE REST OF THE
NATION THAT OUR MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES CAN BENEFIT
EQUITABLY. IN OUR ONGOING
EFFORTS TO PROTECT NATURE SELECT
THE US WENT ABOVE. THANK YOU
MISTER KALRA. SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON MISTER
KALRA THIS ITEM. THIS ONE AT
LEAST. THE CLERK WILL OPEN ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THEM
. ALL MEMBERS VOTE. THE DESIRE
TO VOTE. CLARK WELL. CLOSER ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES SIZE FORTY
EIGHT NO SIXTEEN THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
YEAH. ALL.
OKAY MEMBERS
WE ARE STILL ON THE FILE HERE.
THIS IS FILE ITEM SIXTY FIVE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO TWENTY EIGHT
BY MISTER RODRIGUEZ. AND A
COOKERY ASSEMBLY BILL TWO TWENTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
RODRIGUEZ AND ACKERMAN FIREARMS
MR RODRIGUEZ THANK MISS BECOME
MEMBERS AB TWO TWENTY IT WOULD
REQUIRE THE PARTNER JUSTICE DOES
BACK FARM DEALERS AT LEAST ONE
AT LEAST ONCE EVERY THREE YEARS
TO ENSURE COMPLIANCE WITH FARM
LOS CURRENT LAW ALLOWS THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO INSPECT
FARM DEALERS TO ENSURE
COMPLIANCE WITH FOREIGN LAWS BUT
THERE IS NO REQUIREMENT TO
INSPECT. ON A REGULAR BASIS OR
AT ALL. FARM DEALERS OTHERS
POSSIBLY TO A POOR FARM LAWS TO
PROTECT OUR COMMUNITIES FROM
INDIVIDUALS PROHIBITED BY LAW.
FROM OWNING OR POSITION FIREARM.
WITH INSPECTION RECORDING OF
THIS BILL CALIFORNIA INCREASE
COMPLIANCE FROM FARM DEALERS. TO
ENSURE FARMS DO NOT LAND IN THE
HANDS OF DANGEROUS PEOPLE ARE
RESPECT REALIZED. AFTER I WROTE. THANK YOU MISS RODRIGUEZ
SEEING NO DISCUSSION. WHAT A BET
ON THE ITEM. CORPORAL. IT IS OUT
IT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF IT. ALL MEMBERS VOTE. DESIRABLE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSER AND TYLER
HIGHS SIXTY ONE KNOWS ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. THIS IS FILE
ITEM SIXTY SIX AB TWO EIGHTY
EIGHT. CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
EIGHTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON AND OTHERS SNACK LIVING
SOON FINANCIALLY. MISTER
CALDERON. THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT AB
TWO EIGHT EIGHT WHICH WOULD
PROHIBIT AN INSTITUTION OF
HIGHER EDUCATION FOR REDUCING
THE STUDENTSFINANCIAL AID AWARD
IS THE RESULT OF RECEIVING
PRIVATE SCHOLARSHIP AWARDS A
PRACTICE KNOWN AS SCHOLARSHIP
DISPLACEMENT. THIS BILL WOULD
APPLY TO NEARLY ONE MILLION
STUDENTS IN OUR STATE WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR THE FEDERAL PELL
GRANT OR FINANCIAL AID UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM ACT. AB TWO
EIGHT EIGHT HAS NO OPPOSITION
AND HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. MS BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
AS THE PRIDE JOINT AUTHOR OF AB
TWO EIGHTY EIGHT ALONG WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM WHERE YEAR A
PRIOR TO JOINING YOU ALL ON THIS
BEAUTIFUL GREEN CARPET I SERVED
AS CEO OAKLAND PROMISE A CRADLE
TO COLLEGE AND CAREER INITIATIVE
THAT PROVIDES YOUNG PEOPLE WITH
THE SUPPORT OF RESOURCES THEY
NEED TO THRIVE IN HIGHER
EDUCATION INCLUDING PRIVATE
SCHOLARSHIPS. FOR THAT ROLE I
SAW FIRSTHAND THE WAYS IN WHICH
COLLEGE OF DISPLACEMENT
PERPETUATES FINANCIAL BURDENS ON
STDENTS WHO ALREADY FACE
BARRIERS TO ACCESS ACCESSING
HIGHER EDUCATION IN FACT ONE
STUDENT HAD THE EXPERIENCE OF
ONCE THEY RECEIVE THEIR
FINANCIAL AID AND THEIR
ADMITTANCE TO THEIR DREAM
COLLEGE BECAUSE THEY RECEIVED A
SCHOLARSHIP FROM ROTARY OR
KIWANIS OR MAYBE EVEN ONE OF THE
CAUCUS OF FOUNDATIONS THAT WE'VE
PROVIDED A SCHOLARSHIP JUST LIKE
THAT. THAT THEY HAD TO LITERALLY
MOVE OUT OF THEIR PARENTS HOME
IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO MAKE SURE
THEY COULD USE EVERY DOLLAR THEY
HUSTLED FOR IN SCHOLARSHIP TO BE
ABLE TO APPLY THAT TO THEIR- TO
THEIR DREAM OF GOING TO HIGH ON
TO HIGHER ED. AND THAT'S A SHAME
AND WE CAN CHANGE THAT HERE
STUDENTS PUT IN PART TIME
PUTTING TIME AND EFFORT TO CRAFT
STRONG APPLICATION STERN
SCHOLARSHIPS PROVIDED BY GROUPS
THAT WE LOVE CARE FOR PART OF
OUR COMMUNITY AND THEY SHOULD BE
ABLE TO HAVE THE SCHOLARSHIP
SUPPLY BY PROHIBITING THE
DISPLACEMENT OF FINANCIAL AID
AWARDS DUE TO THE RECEIPT OF
PRIVATE SCHOLARSHIPS FOR
STUDENTS WHO ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
ELIGIBLE FOR THE FEDERAL PELL
GRANTS AND THE CALIFORNIA DREAM
ACT. THIS BILL WILL ENSURE THAT
STUDENTS WHO HAVE FINANCIAL NEED
CAN MAKE FULL USE OF THE AID
THEY RECEIVE RECEIVE TO COVER
THE COST OF COLLEGE THIS WILL
IMPACT TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
STUDENTS WITH. THAT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU MISS BONTA. SEEING NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM. CLICK LIBERAL. ZERO
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF DESIRABLE. CLICK
WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF ISIS
SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES. FIVE SIXTY SEVEN IS AB
THREE ELEVEN BY MISTER WARD
CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
ELEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD
AND OTHERS BACK LEADING FIREARMS
MR WARD. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN THE LEGISLATURE PASSED
AB E. NINETY THREE WHICH
PROHIBITED THE SALE OF FIREARMS
AND AMMUNITIONS AT THE DEL MAR
FAIRGROUNDS HOWEVER THE
LEGISLATION DID NOT SPECIFY
PRECURSOR PARTS ALSO KNOWN AS
GHOST GUN KITS. FURTHER THE CITY
AND THE COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO HAVE
ADOPTED POLICIES WHICH BANNED
THE SALE AND USE OF GHOST GUNS
WITHIN THEIR JURISDICTIONS. AB
THREE ELEVEN WILL FILL THE
INTENT OF AB NINETY THREE EFFORT
TO PROHIBIT THE SALE OF GHOST
GUNS AT THE STATE'S DEL MAR
FAIRGROUNDS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU
MISS WORK. C. NOTIFICATION OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS OF
. DESIRABLE. CLARK WELL. CLOTHES
ARE ALL TIED UP HIGHS FORTY
SEVEN MINUTES TWENTY THAT
MEASURE PASSES. AND THIS IS FILE
ITEM SIXTY EIGHT AB FOUR ELEVEN
CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
ELEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN
AND OTHERS NATURALLY THE
VETERANS HOUSING BY PROVIDING
FUNDS NECESSARY THEIR FOURTH WIN
ELECTION FOR THE ISSUANCE AND
SALE OF BONDS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND HANDLING THE
DISPOSITION OF THOSE FUNDS. IS
THERE WHEN YOU MAY OPEN. MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB FOR
ELEVEN AN AXE THE VETERAN
HOUSING AND HOMELESS PREVENTION
BOND ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO TO
AUTHORIZE THE ISSUANCE OF BONDS
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
THE CONSTRUCTION OF AFFORDABLE
MULTI FAMILY HOUSING WITH
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES FOR
VETERANS. OVER FIVE ROUNDS OF
FUNDING THE VH H. P. HAS
PROVIDED OVER TWENTY SIX.
HUNDRED TOTAL HOUSING UNITS TO
VETERANS AND FORTY EIGHT HUNDRED
TOTAL PROJECT UNITS. THERE ARE
AN ESTIMATED ELEVEN THOUSAND
HOMELESS VETERANS IN CALIFORNIA
AND EVEN MORE EXPERIENCING
HOUSING INSECURITY ARE
STRUGGLING TO MAKE ENDS MEET IN
THE TRANSITION AB FOUR ELEVEN
WILL ASSIST VETERANS WERE
HOMELESS OR WHO NEED AN
AFFORDABLE RENTAL HOUSING OR
NEED AFFORDABLE RENTAL HOUSING
TO SECURE. AND SERVICES FOR
THEIR THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FAMILIES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. ABOUT. THANK YOU MISERY
. SEE NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE ITEM I'M SORRY MR VOEPEL MR
VOEPEL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. OF
COURSE I SUPPORT THIS BILL IT'S
A WONDERFUL BILL. AS A COMBAT
VETERAN. N. ANY VETERAN
ESPECIALLY FEMALE VETERANS THEY
HAVE SPECIAL NEEDS AND SPECIAL
REQUIREMENTS THEY NEED ALL THE
HELP THE- CALIFORNIA CAN GIVE
THEM- A SIDE NOTE MISTER SPEAKER
IS THAT- SORRY. MY NOSE IS STILL
STICKING OUT I'M GOING TO PUT
THAT INTO OKAY. SO A SPECIAL
NOTE IS. AND I'M GOING TO HAVE A
BILL WORKING ON THIS FEMALE
VETERANS HAVE PER CAPITA 65%
HIGHER SUICIDE RATE THE MALE
VETERANS. SO THIS BILL IS
ABSOLUTELY NEEDED. PLEASE VOTE
FOR THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
VOEPEL. SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS
SEEKING RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM
. CLARK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
SERVER ALL MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
VOTE. PALMER SWEATERS ARE THE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLE AND TELL
YOU THAT I SEVENTY NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES. THIS IS FILE
ITEM SIXTY NINE AB FIVE FIVE TWO
SEPARATE. ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
FIFTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
QUIRK SILVA AND ACT WITHIN THE
PEOPLE HEALTH MISS CLARK SILVA.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE FIVE TWO
WOULD ALLOW NOT REQUIRE SCHOOLS
AND COUNTIES TO ENTER INTO THE
INTEGRATED SCHOOL BASED
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PARTNERSHIP
PROGRAM TO PROVIDE EARLY
INTERVENTION IN ACCESS TO
BEHAVIORAL AND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. FOR ALL CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC'S
. PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC REPORTS
HAVE PROVIDED STARTLING
INFORMATION ON THE MENTAL HEALTH
AND BEHAVIOUR LANDSCAPE OF
SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN AND YOUTH
AND NOW DURING THE PANDEMIC THE-
DATA IS ONLY WORSE SCHOOLS AND
HOSPITALS HAVE SEEN A STEADY
RISE IN STUDENTS SUFFERING FROM
TRAUMA. ANXIETY DEPRESSION AND
SUICIDE SOCIAL MEDIA BULLYING
SCHOOL SHOOTINGS FAMILY
SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND POVERTY ARE
JUST SOME OF THE ON UNDERLYING
CAUSES. AS WE ALL KNOW TOO WELL
THE COPA NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS
JUST MADE THIS HEALTH ISSUE A
MAJOR CRISIS FOR OUR YOUNG
STUDENTS. STUDENTS HAVE BEEN AND
OUT IN AND OUT OF SCHOOL FOR
OVER A YEAR SINCE THE PANDEMIC
BIT BEGAN ISOLATION ANXIETY OVER
THE UNCERTAINTY OF THE MEDIA AND
LONG TERM TERM FEE FUTURE LACK.
OF PEER SUPPORT AND CONCERNS
WITH FAMILY HAVE AND WILL
CONTINUE TO TAKE A TOLL WITH
CHILDREN AND YOUTH. BEHAVIOR
HEALTH MENTAL WELLNESS AND
SUPPORT HAVE BEEN CRUCIAL SINCE
STUDENTS RETURNED TO SCHOOL AS A
STATE WE MUST DO EVERYTHING WE
CAN TO ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF OUR
STUDENTS AND TO RELIEVE SOME OF
THE PRESSURE AT SCHOOLS BY
ALLOWING APPROPRIATE. COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS A COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AGENCIES TO
PROVIDE TO PROVIDE BEHAVIORAL
AND MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ON
SCHOOL SITES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MS
CLARK SILVA. SEEN NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ADAM. CLERK WILL
OPEN THEIR ALL. THERE TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY SEVEN NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES THIS IS
FILE ITEM SEVENTY. ASSEMBLY BILL
SIX FORTY SIX BY MR LOW AND THE
CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
FORTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LO
AND OTHERS NATURALLY THE
PROFESSIONS AND VOCATIONS MR LAW
. YOU VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER
AND COLLEAGUES THIS BILL HELPS
TO ENSURE THAT INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE SERVED THEIR TIME HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY COME BACK INTO THE
YSTEM WITH RESPECT TO SOCIETAL
CHALLENGES- BUT HELPS TO ENSURE
THAT WE SET THEM UP FOR SUCCESS
AND NOT FAILURE- THIS IS A
REFORM EFFORT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU MISS LOW SEEING
NO DISCUSSION ON THE ADAM.
CORPORAL THERE. ALL MEMBERS WAS
ADAMANT. ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRABLE. CLARK WELL. CLOSE
ROLE ANTI ABOUT I. SIXTY FIVE NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
IN
FOLLOWER THIS IS FILE ITEM
SEVENTY ONE EIGHTY SIX FIFTY
FIVE AM MISTER KALRA. SYMBOL SIX
FIFTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA AND OTHERS MEDICALLY THE
PEACE OFFICERS MISTER KALRA YOU
MAY OPEN. THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS EIGHTY SIX FIFTY
FIVE THE CALIFORNIA LAW
ENFORCEMENT ACCOUNTABILITY
REFORM ACT. WELL CLARA LAW
ENFORCEMENT JARGON IS TO UNDERGO
COMMONSENSE RECENTLY LIMITED PRE
EMPLOYMENT SCREENING FOR NON
PARTICIPATION IN VIOLENT HATE
GROUPS. THERE IS ABUNDANT
EVIDENCE OF EXTREMIST
INFILTRATION ALL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES WHICH HAS LED TO A
SERIOUS AROCHA PUBLIC TRUST. A
LACK OF MEANINGFUL FEDERAL OR
STATE ACTION IS ONLY EXACERBATED
THIS GROWING ISSUE. IN ADDITION
TO SOME LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
PARTICIPATING IN THE APPALLING
INSTRUCTION THE U. S. CAPITOL
CALIFORNIA'S OWN POLICE
DEPARTMENTS HAVE BEEN PLAGUED
WITH SCANDALS INVOLVING OFFICERS
EXPRESSING RACIST. HOMOPHOBIC OR
THREATENING MESSAGES OVER SOCIAL
MEDIA. ASIDE FROM BEING
IDENTIFIED AT RALLIES ORGANIZED
WHITE SUPREMACIST GROUPS
OFFICERS EXPRESS BLATANT HATE
SPEECH ON SOCIAL MEDIA. AND IN
FRONT OF THEM AS THE COMMUNITIES
OF THEY HAVE BEEN SWORN TO
PROTECT. EXTREMISM RACISM
ANIMALS HAVE NO PLACE AMONG OUR
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AS THEY
ONLY CONTRIBUTE TO THE EROSION
OF PUBLIC CONFIDENCE IN THE
LEGITIMACY AND FAIRNESS OF OUR
JUSTICE SYSTEM. THE CLEAR ACT
ALSO RECOGNIZES NUANCES IN A
PEACE OFFICER'S AFFILIATION WITH
A GROUP. OF A COMPLAINT ALLEGING
BALLOT PAPERS FILED AGAINST KERN
OFFICER. INVESTIGATION WILL BE
TRIGGERED. IF IT'S SUSTAINED IT
COULD BE GROUNDS FOR TERMINATION
. WE WERE THOUGHTFUL FIRST
AMENDMENT PROTECTIONS IN
CRAFTING THIS BILL SPECIFICALLY
THE CLEAR ACT. BILLS OFF THE
STATE'S EXISTING ABILITY TO
LIMIT PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES THE PERSON SPEAKER
INTERFERE WITH THE POSITION'S
DUTIES. IN DOING SO WE WERE
ABLE. TO IN DOING SO WE'RE ABLE
TO OF NOT ONLY HAVE THE US ACLU
MOVE FURNITURE BUT INTO SUPPORT
WITH THE MEN'S TAKEN. LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS PLAY A
CRITICAL ROLE IN OUR COMMUNITIES
AND MUST HAVE THE TRUST THE
PUBLIC THEIR JOB SAFELY AND
EFFECTIVELY. MEMBERS OF OTHER
GROUPS LIKE THE PROBLEM IS THE
KKK HAVE NO PLACE IN OUR LAW
ENFORCING AGENCIES. AS A NOT
BILL TO POSSESS A BADGER THE
AUTHORITY AND POWER THAT COMES
WITH IT. IN OUR WORK WE ALSO-
WORKED WITH- CORRECT. BOB WHO
WERE NEVER OPPOSED THE WE DID A
MENDOZA WE DID. MAKE SOME
AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THE CONCERNS THAT THEY RAISED.
THE CLERK WILL PROBABLY THREE
LONG FORCING CANDIDATES AND
EMPOWER PEOPLE AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO HOLD
OFFICERS ACCOUNTABLE WITHOUT
RESPECT AS RELIABLE. THANK YOU
MISTER KALRA C. NOTIFICATION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM. CORPORAL.
THE SERVER OVER SUPPORTERS OUT
OF A. ALL MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE
TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ALL.
TIDE OF. HIGHS FORTY ONE KNOWS
FOURTEEN. THAT MEASURE PASSES.
THIS IS FILE ITEM SEVENTY TWO A.
B. SIX SIX ONE BY MISTER BENNETT
PRESENTING FROM MS REYES SINCE
DESK. CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL SIX SIXTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BENNETT AN ACT RELATING
TO RECYCLING MISTER BENNETT.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER SB SIX
SIX ONE. IS SAID WOULD MAKE MUCH
NEEDED IMPROVEMENTS THE STATE
AGENCY BY RECYCLE PROGRAM AND
TWENTY NINETEEN THIS LEGISLATURE
UNANIMOUSLY PASSED A BE FIFTEEN
EIGHTY THREE THE FORM THE
STATEWIDE COMMISSION ON
RECYCLING MARKETS IN CURBSIDE
RECYCLING TO MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR HOW THE
STATE CAN REDUCE RECYCLING GOALS
AB SIX SIX ONE SIMPLY ADOPT
THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS. CLIMATE
CHANGE IS THE MOST SERIOUS
THREAT WE FACE AND PURCHASING
MORE RECYCLED PRODUCTS IS JUST
ONE OF MANY STEPS IT'LL HELP US
LOWER OUR CARBON FOOTPRINT. WE
OFTEN ASK BUSINESSES TO
UNDERTAKE EFFORTS IN THE NAME OF
CLIMATE CHANGE HOWEVER GIVEN THE
STATE'S PURCHASING POWER WE MUST
DO OUR PART ALSO AND SEND
EXAMPLE FOR OTHER GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES. WHEREVER APPROPRIATE.%
WE SHOULD USE THE STATE'S BUYING
POWER TO INCREASE OUR USE OF
RECYCLED PRODUCTS. ULSTER
RECYCLING MARKETS AND MOVE
TOWARDS A CIRCULAR ECONOMY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MUCH BETTER. SHE
NOTICED KASHER DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLERK WILL OF THE ROLE.
ZERO ALL MEMBERS VOTE ESERVER.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE TO DECIDE ABOUT. CLARK WELL. CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TYLER HIGHS FIFTY ONE NO SIXTEEN
. THE MEASURE PASSES. THIS IS
FILE ITEM SEVENTY THREE AB NINE
TWENTY THREE BY MISTER RAMOS
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
NINE TWENTY THREE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAMOS AND OTHERS NOT
GOING TO STATE GOVERNMENT
MYSTERONS THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AB NINE TWO THREE
WILL REQUIRE HEADS OF STATE
AGENCIES TO BE PROPERLY TRAINED
AND GOVERNMENT TO GOVERNMENT
CONSULTATION WITH TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS AND CONSIDER
CONSULTATION WITH TRIBES IN THE
POLICY MAKING. WE HAVE SEEN
RECENT EXAMPLES OF THE CONFUSION
THAT TOO OFTEN ARISES AS STATE
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS INTERACT
WITH TRIBES. WE SEE THIS OFTEN
DURING NATURAL EMERGENCIES SUCH
AS WILDFIRES OR EARTHQUAKES AND
MOST RECENTLY DURING THE
PANDEMIC. INFORMATION SHARING
CAN RESULT IN DANGEROUSSITUATIONS AND LACK OF ACCESS TO
AVAILABLE ASSISTANCE. THIS BILL
IS EXPECTED TO HAVE MINIMAL
FISCAL IMPACT WHILE HAVING A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON THE
RELATIONSHIPS AND COLLABORATION
BETWEEN NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBES
AND THE STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ENTITIES. THIS BILL
IS SPONSORED BY THE SALMON WHAT
TRAVEL GOVERNMENT AND THE
MORONGO TRIBAL GOVERNMENT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS ROSS. C.
NOTIFICATION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
SEVERAL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS VOTE IS THAT A
VOTE. CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLE
ANTI VOTE I SEVENTY NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
OKAY MEMBERS WE
ARE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY ON
FILE ITEM. SEVENTY FOUR. PASS
AND RETAIN ON FILE ITEM SEVENTY
FIVE. WE ARE AT FILE ITEM
SEVENTY SIX. AB TWELVE OH SIX BY
MISTER BENNETT FROM IS RAISES
DESK AND THE CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWELVE OH SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BENNETT AND
OTHERS MACINNES TAXATION TO AND
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY TAX
LEVY. MISTER BENNETT THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AB TWELVE OH SIX
SIMPLY PROVIDES PARITY BETWEEN
LAND TRUST AND OTHER FORMS OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
PROTECTING THEM IN THE RESIDENTS
FROM UNEXPECTED INCREASES IN
THEIR PROPERTY TAX BILLS THIS
BILL GOT OUT OF BOTH REVENUE TAX
AND HOUSING WITH BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
BENNET. SENIOR DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM CORPORAL OF
THE ROLE. IT IS OUR TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE CEREMONY. ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS ARE ABOUT. CLARK
WELL. CLOSER ALL ANTI VOTE I
SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES THIS IS FILE ITEM SEVENTY
SEVEN AB TWELVE FORTY BY MR
TINKLER COREY. SOME PEOPLE
TWELVE FORTY BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
TING ACKLINGTON AIR POLLUTION
MISTER CHANG. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB TWELVE FORTY UPDATES
THE CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES
BOARD TWENTY YEAR PUBLIC HEALTH
STUDY TO IMPROVE THE SCIENCE ON
SOURCES OF INDOOR AIR POLLUTANTS
IN THE POTENTIAL HEALTH EFFECTS
RECENT AMENDMENTS PROVIDE MORE
TIME FOR THE DATA TO BE
SUBMITTED. A. B. TWELVE FORTY
ENJOYS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND NO
OPPOSITION RESPECTFULLY ASK FIVE
. THANK YOU MICHELLE. SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ADAM
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ZERVOS. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF. ALL
MEMBERS REPRESENTATIVE OF. CLARK
WELL CLOSE ROLE ANTI THAT I
SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
GO BACK TO PICK UP MISTER
MCCARTY IS FILE ITEM. FIFTY
THREE. I RISE TO PRESENT. I
THINK ANYBODY. YEAH. ACTUALLY.
JUST ONE SECOND US REGARDING.
MCCARTY I'M SORRY I NEED TO
DOUBLE CHECK WITH YOU IF YOU
WANT TO TAKE UP THE EVER SEVENTY
NUMBER SEVEN FOUR. PRESSURE
MEMBERS THIS IS FILE ITEM
SEVENTY FOUR FILE ITEM. SEVENTY
FOUR. ASSEMBLY BILL TEN FOURTEEN
BY MR MCCARTY CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN FOURTEEN BY%
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY
IMMACULATE CANVAS MISTER CARTY
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TO PRESENT THIS BILL WHICH WOULD
AMEND IT NEEDED TWO THIRDS VOTE
THEY ARE CANNABIS- LEGISLATION
THAT WENT BEFORE THE VOTERS A
FEW YEARS AGO- FRANKLY ALLOWING
LEGAL OPERATORS TO COMPETE MORE
AGAINST THE ILLICIT MARKET. ALL
RIGHT NOW FOR- MOBILE DELIVERY-
DISPENSARIES THEY CAN ONLY HAVE
UP TO FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
WORTH OF CANNABIS GOODS IN THEIR
IN THEIR VEHICLE- THIS IS THE
EQUIVALENT TO ABOUT ONE- SMALL
BRIEFCASE OF CANNABIS PRODUCTS.
WE DID AMEND THE SIGNIFICANTLY
TO LOWER THE THRESHOLD AT A SOME
CONCERNS FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT SO
WE ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES BOB IN
ADDITION BECAUSE MOST LICENSE
RETAILERS AREN'T URBAN CITIES
60% OF CALIFORNIANS MOST LOCATED
IN RURAL CALIFORNIA OF COURSE
MUST DRIVE OVER AN HOUR OR MOR
TO ILLEGAL CANNABIS STORE. OFTEN
DELIVERY DRIVERS CAN'T REACH
THESE CUSTOMERS BEFORE RUNNING
OUT OF PRODUCT AND THEY HAVE TO
GO BACK TO THE RETAILER TO RE TO
GET MORE- YOU KNOW DOESN'T
FOLLOW THESE RULES THE LEGAL AND
THE ILLICIT MARKET SO THIS
ALLOWS FRANKLY FAIR COMPETITION-
THIS LACK OF ACCESS INCENTIVIZE
PEOPLE TO PURCHASE FROM THE
ILLEGAL MARKET WHICH IS
UNREGULATED. UNTAXED AND
UNTESTED PUTTING CALIFORNIANS IN
THE LEGAL MARKET AT RISK- THIS I
THINK IS A FAIR FIX WENT THROUGH
A POLICY COMMITTEE WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE RIVAL THANK
YOU. THANKS FOR CARD SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE. ON THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. THE
SERVER ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
THE.
THIS TAKES.
FIFTY FOUR. MR
MCCARTY MOVES A CALL.
MEMBERS I
AM PREPARED TO LIFT THE CALL ON
MR MCCURDY'S ITEM. THIS IS FILE
ITEM SEVENTY FOUR AB TEN
FOURTEEN CLERK WILL POST. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED WHICH TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS WHO WISH TO VOTE.
ALL
MEMBERS FEDERATION ABOUT THIS
TAKES FIFTY FOUR.
MR MCCARTY
REPLACES A CALL.
OKAY MEMBERS WE
ARE ON THE FILE. MR GALLAGHER IS
READY TO TAKE UP. FILE ITEM
SEVENTY EIGHT A. B. TWELVE FORTY
NINE. CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL
TWELVE FORTY NINE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GALLAGHER AND OTHERS
NEGLIGENCE TAXATION MAKING A
PROBATIONER FOR DECLARING YOUR
TO SEE EITHER OF SIGNIFICANTLY.
MISTER CALDERON. I THINK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS- I RISE
TO PRESENT AB TWELVE FORTY NINE
A VERY AN IMPORTANT BILL- THAT
WOULD CLARIFY THAT SETTLEMENT
PAYMENTS RECEIVED OUT OF P.
GENIES WILDFIRE VICTIMS TRUST.
WOULD BE. TAX FREE- FOR VICTIMS
IN MY DISTRICT IN MY COLLEAGUES
DISTRICTS- WILDFIRE VICTIMS OF
THE CAMPFIRE AND OF THE BUTTE
FIRE OF THE NORTH BAY FIRES THEY
HAVE BEEN WAITING FAR TOO LONG
TO GET THEIR SETTLEMENT PAYMENTS
IN THE FIRST PLACE THEY LOST
LOVED ONES LOST THEIR HOMES LOST
THEIR PROPERTY. AND I'VE BEEN
WAITING TO BE COMPENSATED.
POLICE THAT WE CAN DO IS TO
ENSURE THAT THAT COMPENSATION.
WILL BE TAX FREE MANY OF THESE
VICTIMS HAD TO GO THROUGH ALL
THE UPS AND DOWNS OF THE
BANKRUPTCY. AND OUT OF THAT
BANKRUPTCY CAME THIS TRUST. IT
IS GOING TO PAY OUT AND FINALLY
PROVIDE THAT COMPENSATION AS YOU
MAY HAVE HEARD THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF PROBLEMS WITH THAT. AND
THERE'S- MAYBE EVEN REPORTS
THAT. THE SETTLEMENT THAT WAS
AGREED TO THE AMOUNT MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO REACH THE REACH. THERE'S
A LOT OF WORK WE NEED TO DO TO
ENSURE. THAT OUR WILDFIRE
VICTIMS VICTIMS OF. FIRES THAT
WERE CAUSED BY PG&E. ARE
COMPENSATED BUT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT CAN REALLY HELP
THAT MONEY GO A LONG WAY BY
MAKING IT TAX EXEMPT AND I WANT
TO THANK ALL MY COLLEAGUES TO
HELP ME IN WORKING ON THIS BILL-
IT'S BEEN A IT'S BEEN A BI
PARTISAN EFFORT. AND WE'RE GONNA
DO SOME GOOD THINGS FOR THESE
VICTIMS SO I APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY FOR THIS VERY
IMPORTANT BILL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISS GALLAGHER. C.
NOTIFICATION FOR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
DESIRABLE ALL MEMBERS FOR THIS
ARTICLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE THIS TAKES FIFTY
FOUR. CLARK WELL. CLOSER ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE IS FIFTY NINE NO
ZERO ON THE URGENCY HIGHS FIFTY
NINE NO ZERO ON THE BILL. THAT
MEASURE PASSES. AND THIS IS FILE
ITEM SEVENTY NINE AB TWELVE
EIGHTY EIGHT BY MISS CLARK SILVA
CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE
EIGHTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
QUIRK SILVA AND ACT LEADING TO
TAXATION TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY. MS CLARK
SILVA THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS FOR THE LAST THREE YEARS
THE STATE BUDGET HAS INCREASED
ITS INVESTMENT IN LOW INCOME
HOUSING TAX CREDIT PROGRAM BY
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS PER
YEAR. AB TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT
GIVES US A BIGGER BANG FOR THE
BUCK BY MAXIMIZING OUR
PRODUCTION OF AFFORDABLE HOMES
BY ALLOWING THE TAX CREDIT
ALLOCATION COMMITTEE TO PAIR THE
STATE. TAX CREDITS WITH EITHER
4% OR 9% THREATEN FEDERAL CREDIT
AS CONDITIONS BEST DICTATE. AND
TWENTY NINETEEN CALIFORNIA
PAIRED THE STATE CREDITS WITH 4%
FEDERAL CREDITS BECAUSE THE FOUR
PERCENT. FEDERAL CREDITS WERE
UNDER SUBSCRIBED AT THAT TIME
SINCE THEN CONDITIONS HAVE
DRAMATICALLY CHANGED AND THE 4%
CREDIT. ARE NOW OVER SURPRISE
SURPLUS OF SCRIBE BY THREE TO
ONE AND FEDERAL RULES DO NOT
ALLOW US TO EXPAND THAT PROGRAM
. HOWEVER THERE IS NO FEDERAL
BERIO TO EXPANDING THE 9%
FEDERAL CREDIT PROGRAM THEREFORE
IF. UNDER THESE CONDITIONS WE
PER THE STATE CREDITS WITH 9%
FEDERAL CREDITS WE CAN FUND
ADDITIONAL AFFORDABLE HOMES AB
TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT DOES NOT
INCREASE TAXES IN ANY WAY
BECAUSE THE AMOUNT OF CREDITS IS
FIXED IN THE BUDGET EACH YEAR.
AB TWENTY TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT
SIMPLY IS MORE EFFECTIVE AND
IMPACTFUL WAY FOR CALIFORNIA TO
FLORIDA IT'S SCARCE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING RESOURCES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISS WORK SO. SENIOR DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM. THE
CORPORAL. RESERVE VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTE YOU DESIRE TO VOTE
. THIS TAKES FIFTY FOUR VOTES.
ALL MEMBERS FOR THE DESIRE TO
VOTE THIS TAKES FIFTY FOUR.
CLERK WILL. CLOSER ROLE AND
TALLY THE VOTE IS FIFTY SIX NO
ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO TAKE
OF MISS REVERSES FILE ITEM
EIGHTY ONE. A. B. NINE SEVENTY
FIVE OPERATE. ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
SEVENTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THREE OF US AN ACTIVITY TO THE
POLITICAL REFORM ACT OF NINETEEN
SEVENTY FOUR. MYSTERY OF US
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
AB NINE SEVENTY FIVE DOES TWO
THINGS FIRST IT REQUIRES PUBLIC
OFFICIALS AND CANDIDATES FOR
WHOM THE F. PPC IS THE FILING
OFFICER TO FILE THEIR STATEMENTS
OF ECONOMIC INTEREST FORM SEVEN
HUNDRED ELECTRONICALLY. SECONDLY
THIS BILL RECONCILES THE
TIMELINE FOR A PUBLIC OFFICIAL
TO REIMBURSE THE COST OF
ADMISSION TO AN INVITATION ONLY
EVENT WITH THE DEADLINE FOR A
LOBBYIST EMPLOYER TO NOTIFY. THE
OFFICIAL OF THE VALUE OF
ATTENDING THE EVENT. AB NINE
SEVENTY FIVE WILL FREE UP A PPC
STAFF RESOURCES TO IMPROVE
EFFICIENCY IN GOVERNMENT AND
INCREASE TRANSPARENCY. THE BILL
DOES NOT HAVE ANY OPPOSITION
THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU THREE
OF US SAY NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
ON THIS ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. IT IS OUR TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF A CLERK
WILL. CLOSER ROLE AND TELL YOU
VOTE I SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS WE STILL
HAVE ONE ITEM ON CALL.
MEMBERS I
AM PREPARED TO LET THE CALL ON
RUSSIA CARTES AB TEN FOURTEEN
CORP WILL POST. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS FOR
. WHO WISH TO VOTE. WELL CLOSE
THE ROLE. TELL YOU VOTE HIGHS
FIFTY FIVE. NO. SIX THAT MEASURE
PASSES PASS RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS
EIGHTY THREE THROUGH EIGHTY SIX
ON SENATE THIRD READING.
MEMBERS
WE ARE AT ANNOUNCEMENTS.
SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS. TUESDAY
FEBRUARY FIRST CHECK IN SESSION
. WEDNESDAY FEBRUARY SECOND
CHECK IN SESSION THURSDAY
FEBRUARY THIRD FLOOR SESSION IS
AT NINE AM ALL OF THE ITEMS
REMAINING WILL BE PASSED RETAIN
A MOTION SHALL BE CONTINUED
SEEING INTERNET FOR THE BUSINESS
AYE READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION
TO ADJOURN MS REYES MOVES AND
MISS WALDRON SECONDS THAT THIS
HOUSE MS JOURN UNTIL THURSDAY
FEBRUARY THIRD NINE AM. IN THE
QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED.